so you can perfect
[Music]
all right all right we're back what's up
guys it's a new week
happy [__] monday if you're on
your way to work
i'm sorry but i hope it's a good day
hope you make it a good day and i hope
we could put you in a good mood
if you're at home if you're at school if
you're just at work chilling in the
break room
thank you for giving us some of your day
thank you for taking the time out of
your day to say what up to us
and we got some [__] to talk about today
all right this is the dope as usual
podcast guys thank you so much for
joining us we are here to talk about
life problems accomplishments drugs and
everything in between
i am your host dopaziola thank you guys
so much for joining us
and let's get into another episode so
real quick
if you're like me you're a fan of comedy
obviously if you're if you're
into the comedy world into stand-up
comedians you follow them online
you already know what the [__] is going
on with this next situation but
i feel i want to talk about it i asked
mari like should
should we talk about this but yeah why
the [__] not it's in the news it's not
like it's [__]
a secret so let me just start off like
this
i went to the comedy store maybe four
years three years ago
and i was watching i think it was joe i
first i ever saw joey diaz actually
um and this guy came on stage i had no
idea who the [__] he wasn't never heard
of him i
never heard of his name his name is
chris talia never knew who he was
he got on stage i laughed for [__] 30
minutes and i was a fan
instantly a fan i had no idea who he was
and
that [__] is funny right so
beside from being funny you guys have
seen what's in the news i'm not here to
say you're guilty because i have no idea
what the [__] i'm not a cop let's just
put it that i'm not a cop
so we're here to talk about what we do
know and what we do know is what's in
the news
a couple days ago guys i saw a video pop
up it was crystalline his face he did
not
look happy and i go get the [__] out of
your new video
if you're not following what's going on
about maybe what getting a quarantine
marty last year
right maybe around this time last year
actually somewhere around somewhere
around there i could be wrong but
chris delete got super [__] canceled
all right let's just say that you got
[__] canceled if you were from the
ghetto you are stomped out
cancelled yeah you know what the [__]
i'm saying you get run out of the
of the neighborhood canceled so for
those of you living under a [__] rock
or you don't give a [__]
he got accused of all this [__] i
understand i'm not here to pick sides
i am not on that side that side is a
pervert side
so what we know so far marty if i'm
wrong stop me and say hey you're [__]
wrong
from what i get he's messaging girls
like people do
and when you're famous and you're
[__] funny and you've got money
it's easier all right we'll just say
that it's probably a lot
[__] easier to get girls when you're
a funny [__] and you're rich oh
[__] you're famous
yeah it's a it's a trifecta for getting
[__] you know what i'm saying like
that's
what it's for so this guy was going
around um slaying girls
state to state which is fine [__] it do
it that's what you're supposed to do if
you want to
but then it starts coming out a lot of
these girls aren't even 18
not 18 16 15
some 14 and that is [__] disgusting
i'm not like i said i'm not a cop i'm
not there in the interrogation room i
don't know what's true
but from what i'm seeing it's just true
i watched a couple clips man and when
they talk about [__] snapchat
you can see the the happiness just
disappear
what do you mean they save snapchats and
you can see his eyes go
[__] oh god dude you can see the look on
his face when he realized
i might be [__] well
let's say this right now all the ones
that i all the all the conversations i
saw
were girls that were overage i didn't
see the underage ones
i'm not saying they're not real at all
because i'm not
i'm saying the ones i saw were a guy
hitting on a girl a little aggressively
close your [__] app don't answer him
back
but i get it if you're underage you're
susceptible to oh my god he's [__]
famous oh
you're talking to me i get that i
understand
the mind of a kid because i was a
[__] kid too and when you're saying
kid in the same context of trying to
[__] you're a creep
that's there's no other word to say like
i said i'm not
i don't know if what's true or what's
not the reason i bring that up is
because as soon as that happened this
[__] took a dive off the end of
the world and did not show his face
turned off all the com once you start
turning the comments off on your
instagram and [__]
something's wrong once you start because
when you're when you're not guilty you
go
[__] you fool say whatever you want i
know what the [__] i did unless you're
trying to hide some [__]
i'm not like i said i'm not a cop so i'm
not here to say that and before we get
into the rest of this let me light this
[__] joint up
hold up light this joint so like i said
the other day i saw
i was on youtube and i clicked past it
and i had to scroll back like was that
[__] crystalia
yeah so this guy did a um like i said
guys aside from all that i know i'm not
taking sides or anything
that motherfucker's funny i'm not gonna
say he's not funny you can be funny and
a [__] creep
you guys know that i'm not gonna support
further of creepiness but if what he's
saying is true he's gone
i mean what if people are what he's
saying is true he's completely gone
but what i got marty uh did you watch
the apology video
i sure did oh i sure did i can already
tell your stance on this
um for what i got of that was an apology
for being caught i didn't really get the
he didn't really dabble he didn't really
get into the whole hey remember when
they said the [__] about kids
my bad it didn't but then again like i
said
who knows the only people that know are
the people involved and the cops
right you're under investigation for
[__] sure the reason i bring this up
is because this morning now he's getting
allegation now he's getting sued
civil suit by a girl that was underrated
saying that he was basically grooming
her or forcing her to send pictures
let's just say this from a fan from a
human standpoint
i really hope none of this shit's true
that's
i'm sure we all everyone listening right
now i know if you're listening to this
you're probably chris to leah fan
because you like comedy you like funny
[__]
i hope that shit's not true and for
everyone that's a friend of him
you could still be the guy's friend and
not like what he did do you understand
you don't dissociate no more
but you don't have to oh i don't know
that person
who chris who shut the [__] up every
comedian out there saying chris who
suck a dick when [__] are down
you're not friends but when they're up
everything's cool you guys are tagging
and posting
you fake [__] all right if one
of my friends did that [__] i go yo i
love you bro but don't ever call me
again i can't i can't [__] with you
i love you so much but you're a [__]
creep that's the way it works but then
again
when people see the benefit when people
see opportunity they uh
i mean look chips are down no one
[__] cares about crystallia
but when he was up everyone wants to be
around crystalia
it's annoying it's annoying at least
take a stance to be honest like yo that
[__] [__] up he's a creep i can't
associate with him but yeah he was my
friend
because that's the truth you know i'm
saying that's that's the truth you can't
beat around the truth
so as of right now that shit's all bad
for if you like i said if you have no
idea what's going on
i haven't seen a career just end like
that in a long time that [__] was
[__] weird everyone's on top of the
world
on top of the [__] world marty in a
different way
in a different [__] way he's on top
of the world like on a
on a rise on a [__] rise dude and
who how sad that the last [__] role
he played in the show was a pedophile
dude do they really need to do that [__]
if i was doing some creepy [__] i
wouldn't take the role
it wouldn't take the role that i'm
living
oh [__] it was too much that's like sean
connery really being a spy
what the [__]
i don't know man but i wanted to talk
about that because it's
not i see it everywhere i go and like me
and marty said we do these uh
we're trying to do these podcasts closer
to the release date because right now
last week's podcast comes out in two and
a half to three weeks we're just trying
to be ahead of ourselves because we
don't want to be
oh [__] hurry up but at the same time if
we did that this crystallise [__] this
is three weeks ago
so we're trying to do we're trying to
catch up on ourselves so if you guys
catch the little news like you know what
happened last week
that's because we did it the day of all
right so um
marty what are your thoughts on this
crystal situation honestly honestly
without being around the bush because i
know you [__] work with these people
closely
you as a human you as a human and hold
on
you're not a dad in this situation just
as a human not a dad
yeah because you're a dad with a
daughter around that age so yeah
i mean i first of all i think it's
really important to acknowledge just
like
how quickly the tables can turn because
this dude was on the top of
the [__] world man prior to this
happening one of the biggest podcast
stars
multiple netflix specials huge community
show funny as
a theater comic there's different levels
of comics too at the same time a theater
comic is
that second the joke yeah selling out
theaters is different
and he was just on a tear unlike any i
mean
like anything i had really seen and uh
so i mean as far as that goes i like to
just take note like
they will turn on you it can all be over
but at the same time if you give people
a reason to that's on you yeah
exactly for me in this type of situation
anytime something like this is involved
i always would like the cops to get
involved
like off the bench shouldn't you off the
bat what the [__] because you're famous
the cops aren't there this is a [__]
sexual allegation it's a weird thing to
be able to like
to time it and to like get get somebody
through the media like this and cancel
them
and i get it like if that is you you
totally deserve that you deserve to go
to jail [__]
no whatever you deserve to go to jail
and it's going to be real bad for you
what i just
what i don't like is the use of the
media like this like what i mean okay he
put out his little
uh you know premeditated i'm sorry video
and then the next day he sued
like right and that seems a little i
that
marty is [__] [__] they had that
they had that article they had that
lawsuit three days ago there's a real
situation with a kid
that's being harassed by an adult or
is being taken advantage of and all this
stuff and there's the hundreds of
pictures and all this [__]
there's pictures get them oh yeah
there's hundreds of pictures that's what
the whole thing is what do you mean what
do you mean pictures of what of oh of
them sending [__] to him
yeah did he ask yeah
listen again i don't know this dude i
don't know [__] i can legitimately say i
don't know this dude
and i you know i know what just what
i've been reading about
but yeah i mean that's the whole crux of
it is soliciting uh you know these type
of materials from underage people
and then beyond that no in my mind
nobody's going to come out and make this
type of stuff up i mean they could it
says
well the day after yeah that's the crazy
part that's why it's like
you wait for him to show his face again
and go no no no no no that that's what
he's the final stamp
like because i've had people in my life
really
impact my the whole trajectory of my
life as a kid
like through my family was impacted by
[__] like this big time
changed the whole course of my life so
i'm very sensitive to it on top of
having two daughters
so like is that as far as that goes like
if i found out a grown man was texting
my daughter
oh i'd go to jail bro i like that that's
that you walk around vulnerable as a dad
because it's like
i know my freedom's on the line over
these kids at all times that's something
where i'm
at your door i'm waiting for you type of
[__] like what else am i gonna do
can't go about life no you can't go to
sleep or or call the cops whatever it's
going to be something needs to be done
but just i just i don't know i don't
feel like
oh he made an i'm sorry video now file
the lawsuit like
get the headlines yeah it should all
happen at the same [__] time yeah if
she went to court right [__] parents
when this happened the parents should
have been on it they should have did
what they're going to do if there's
hundreds
hundreds of these girls or whatever i
don't know man and i'm not blaming
parents or blaming these kids because
it's not they're [__]
these kids are susceptible to [__] like
this kids don't tell their parents [__]
yeah especially when they're like they
probably love this [__]
and they're fans ordering on adults like
that's the other gray area where it's
like when you're sixth like you think
back when you're 16.
you were 16 year old 15 years old
that but we're talking about a grown man
and we're talking a grown man with fame
and power
exactly and all that so it's like you
can't go to jail for being a scumbag
all performers if you were to audit all
musicians and
entertainers like you're not gonna like
what you find in terms of how they treat
people or their
sex lives and [__] like that but this is
just a different level it's a whole
different level this is
this is uh the probably the biggest
[__] thing that's ever happened to a
comedian honestly
yeah because he was so violently
cancelled
that it became like it's almost like a
little industry now
like hate on him yeah but then again if
that shit's real
well you deserve every [__] bit of it
yeah
if it's real and but even if it's like
kind of real even if it's like you told
that lying to being a scumbag with kids
like i'm just it's real
if you knew if you know put this way
if i was talking to some girl and she
looked 25 and i found out she's 17
i erase the number and block it
immediately no but i think
you're a creep the article is what the
article is like he knows that
he's like he's into like repeat to me
how old you are
like really like lean in like the
younger the better type of [__] that's
where it goes off into a whole nother
level where it's like
i don't know how the cops aren't
involved because i feel like if to be a
regular person got
any allegation even if it's not even
[__] proven you're in jail if
somebody says that [__] is a regular
person yeah about kids like
that's it it's over yeah the whole thing
is weird it's weird how they did that
like
how it originally happened and then like
the la times saw
all that web traffic and now they're
waging campaigns on calendar whether
it's real or not
who knows whether it's real or not it's
it's just
unbelievable man it's it's it's a movie
this is a [__] piece of a movie where
a guy loses his career
but what it's not is it's not like a
canceled culture
i mean this is real [__] this is not
part of the
cancel him he said something homophobic
it's cancel him and [__] send him to
jail and never let him perform again
because this guy's a pedophile
if it's real like i said i know a lot of
comedians are out there if you see this
and you're like well [__] this kid who
is this guy pocket suck my dick
you [__] creep all right if you have
a problem with what we're saying about
your friend
say something to us i don't know i just
feel like we're in this we're in this
stage of like
brand new podcast who the [__] are you
to talk about our friend like that
suck my dick that's how i feel yeah me
too
a hundred percent i don't give a [__]
because we're in la we're in this realm
marty's in the podcast realm he's in the
comedian circuit he knows all these
people
this is they know you me through you
like who's this [__] kid talking [__]
on the internet over here
[__] off this is the start of our this
is this is how this podcast is gonna be
all right
it's okay to talk about relevant [__]
yeah your own genuine thoughts
exactly and um are my final thought on
that is like
i hope it's not real and if it is eat a
dick
and that's it nothing else to say about
it and if you agree or you're still
sympathize you're [__] creeped too if
it is real
i think he did the best thing by just
like fading fading away
bro move to [__] alaska [__] spain
go somewhere that shit's [__] legal
[__]
other countries asian can sense like
[__] 16. if you're into that [__]
move because over here you're gonna get
stomped the [__] out in public in jail
the comedy's everywhere you go you're
not allowed for the rest of life that's
the other thing the rest of life you're
in l.a [__] you catch one
mexican
catching one gang banger motherfucker's
gonna kill your ass
you know marty i don't think these
people understand it's gonna be
terrifying
[__] terrifying bro you have to think
about it
you pull some [__] you're famous you
don't know who the [__] recognizes you
you could be at bj's [__] bar and
grill
and get stabbed in the neck that [__]
you are in prison
terms for the rest of your life as a
pedophile because that's some pedophile
[__]
if that's real sorry we have to come
back because i'm sorry to throw them
under the bus but
if that's real but as of now speculation
until this time
in my mind if i get accused of something
i didn't do i'm never going to sleep
until i prove around the last thing i'm
doing is hiding
i won't even sleep i'll stand up all
[__] day but like bring every person
that said that [__]
what was that chappelle where he's like
you gotta believe me
please bless me like [__] like that oh
what was it please believe me
i could just hear the voice i don't
remember
i don't remember damn it um
but yeah sorry i had to start off a
little [__] up but
um that's what's going on and if you're
his friend i'm sorry i
talked about your friend and now let's
move on
sorry justin bieber that your [__]
friend is
in the news all right and just to be
rosie ran into just
multiple [__] times randomly at some
places and i hear nothing but good
things
so i think justin bieber might be a
really nice guy but yeah sorry justin
bieber your favorite comedian might be a
[__] creep
but we'll continue that conversation
we were just talking about the [__] at
our meeting earlier if you just told me
you know first of all comedy's over like
the [__] with chris
the biggest one of the biggest rising
stars in the world
in the world in the [__] world just
stops
this this is a um like i said this is a
sitcom this is a [__] movie this is
pre-planned it feels like it feels like
so
unreal because it was like i said top of
the world let's get off the subject
though
um let's get off the subject good little
kids all right all right all right
guys let's talk about something else you
guys don't want to hear about
um i don't talk about covet a lot i
don't talk about any of that [__]
because we're [__] tired of hearing
about it
but one thing i am going to say is i'm i
wear my mask
i don't care if you call me a [__]
what do you call it uh sheeple
uh eat a dick i got covered in [__]
december
that just [__] sucks if you guys
didn't know that
me and rosie got that [__] in december
it was the flu times five
it [__] sucked if i was over 60 i
felt like i wouldn't have got up again
i was sitting there going how the [__]
are old people getting through this
i was shaking my eyes hurt to look
around
i couldn't really like eat anything i
couldn't smell or taste for three days
and then my stomach pains and my body
aches and i'm sitting there the only
[__] thing that helped me was weed
all the medicines like the night quills
and [__] i stopped taking just started
smoking bowls
that's it my lungs for a lung infection
my lungs were perfectly fine
i got lucky without that i'd be [__]
because everything hurt on my body
even my eyes except for my lungs i could
still take bong rips
we took bomb ribs watched all the
godfathers
watch the irishman and you need two
weeks to watch all the godfathers in the
irishman because that's just long
what else do i watch every christmas
movie you can think of and that's that
was
rosie and i [__] covet binge that
[__] sucked
so the reason i bring that up is be
careful out there i'm not saying
everyone's got cove and all this
[__] just
be careful out there all right um maybe
wear that mask
maybe maybe maybe fist bump a stranger
you know what i'm saying
um the reason i bring this up is because
march 10th you crazy [__] out
there in texas
uh also every time i think of texas and
i'm not downplaying texas my [__]
family's from texas all right
i just think of spongebob when he's
trying to get sandy not to go back he's
like dumbo
texas that's how i feel right now
because
march 10th did you i told you about this
marty march 10th
it's the work it might as well be called
game
on timeout's over because they're going
back to normal life
full capacity and you don't have to wear
a mask
i get it i understand we're supposed to
get out there and live our lives
you're not going to catch me full
capacity anything i'm [__] good
i got that [__] it's not fake this [__]
sucks
and it hurts so um texas for everybody
out there in texas i got
a lot of homies out there be safe
because they just passed that [__] it's
all in the news
starting march 10th no more mass full
capacity
everything's back to normal if i'm wrong
please let me know but
from what i've read that's what's going
on i don't know
how the [__] that doesn't have the most
people or do we have the most people out
of the country
i don't [__] know about aren't they
in the midst of uh
emergency yeah that's right there's what
are the reasons
yeah i know i know you guys all got the
sniffles well let's go back to normal
because
[__] drives up how ironic like you're
all stuck in the inside but
no you can come out you can come out
nope no no mass i know you've been in
the snow for 10 days
yeah i know you've been drinking dirty
water but come outside and say what up
i'm wearing a mask for the next five
years i'm wearing a [__] mask
just until some of the [__] dies down
because
i know i know it's bad i know the
world's changed when i see a
[__] with a mat without a mask i
go
selfish [__] that's all i think
you selfish [__]
when i forget my mass i'm in the
elevator i put my shirt over even if i
stretch my collar because i feel so bad
it's like not wearing pants it's the new
not wearing shoes
worse though it's all it is more
offensive than people it makes me sad
though because i was somewhere yesterday
and some lady coughed next to me and i
went oh again internally i went get away
from me
it never used to be like that i feel so
weird around people and
they if this was the plan all along to
make us not want to be around each other
you guys won
i'm just gonna say that i'm and plus i'm
busy i'm busy as [__] i got [__] to do
i'm i i see my friends like what three
times a month
that's pretty much it i don't hang out
with [__] no more but i made a
plan to i made it a point to be busy
so we don't go around as many people
until the [__] dies down i just saw my
mom for the first time and i don't know
how [__] long
because my mom's got she's like a high
risk because she has a disease and [__]
so
i haven't seen her i haven't seen my
little brother they've been quarantined
since last march man
they haven't left a [__] house guys
in a year
that's just unreal i mean good thing
they live in the country it's a lot of
property but
damn i could not sit in the house only
for a year i'd go crazy
so um it's officially almost been a year
and uh
just wanted to bring that up march 10th
texas is getting [__] crazy
uh game on in texas would that have
happened without this
disaster they had i don't know granted i
don't know anything but it just seems
like a crazy coincidence
it just seems like a little uh a little
risky
it seems a little risky right yeah i
mean it's
all right ready the equivalent of texas
and going back to normal is the
equivalent of like yo man i'm not
looking can i cross the street
yeah there's no cars man cross it's like
yeah that's a lot of confidence in that
part i don't feel like anything's really
happened
to like warrant that though right like
it's not like i think they're all just
sitting there going
well i haven't hunted in so long and
that's what that is what it is i just
think of texas as there's austin and
there's a bunch of desert
yeah i've never been i'm not talking
[__] i'm just saying that
i have no knowledge but yeah they're
going back march 10th so if you're in
texas
you're [__] ready all right get ready
for that [__]
um something else is the news i brought
this up to marty before the podcast
i don't know which books guys i don't
know which books are banned or whatever
but
i saw in the news that they're gonna
stop printing certain dr seuss books
because of certain racist connotations
uh we live in america [__]
everything's racist here
all right which books and i don't
remember green eggs and ham calling
saying that i'm a [__] i don't remember
anything like i don't remember dr seuss
or the grinch going
hey wyatt's only pie none of that [__]
what thank you for looking it up what
books racist images
what the [__] racist in dr seuss but
then again
i did not read dr seuss i just looked at
the [__] pictures and left
and to think i saw it on mulberry street
that's the book
what he's just smoking weed it looks
like it like clouds around him
i don't know guys but think i want you
to put this in perspective
because a certain amount of people went
we think it's racist and offensive
take it down those [__] never
seen blazing saddles
i'm gonna say that right now marty have
you seen blazing saddles
no it is so [__] offensive and it's
one of the funniest things ever
you guys gotta remember not all right
ready
not everybody likes christmas movies but
if i find them offensive are we gonna
stop making christmas movies
of course not exactly how the [__] can a
certain amount of people go hey you know
what
these dr seuss books kinda racist what's
next
you know that guy thomas he says [__] a
lot
and he talks [__] about everything
and he smokes weed can we cancel i mean
they already are
they already are [__] censoring my
[__] damn it that was probably a bad
example
[__] um i don't know something else
something else look what happened to
colin kaepernick's ass speaking of
what happened to him he took a
[__] knee and the people that
fought for the right for him to take the
knee
or man and i full all right look at
ready
i am on this side of the fence when it
comes to that kneeling [__]
because i get both sides both sides are
right
can we can we can't both sides be right
yes
half side says hey i fought for this
country don't kneel it's disrespectful
i agree with you you fought you had
[__] die next to you
you remember their names you saw their
moms after the war i
get that [__] i get it it's
disrespectful
the reason you fought is for the freedom
to do what you want
so is it the freedom to do things that
only you like
which sounds like a dictatorship which
is what you're fighting against
see you see i wish i could talk to a
racist ass [__] just sit down
and go hey man
i need five minutes with your stupid ass
and i would literally talk
then again racist [__] are
super close-minded they wouldn't get
even if they noticed they were wrong
they wouldn't say that they were wrong
um where does it stop dr seuss books
if a children's book's too offensive
where the [__] is or we marty
i feel like there was some legit racial
books when i was in high school
like what like the the huck finns and
the mark twains i don't [__] know so
they had some heavy duty um little known
fact
i've only read like four books yeah
that's why i don't even know what i'm
but i'm saying
i remember a bunch of uh you know like
that was in the 1800s it was said yeah
but it's like it's a time piece
yeah yeah exactly it's for the time
[__]
it's not all about [__] racial slurs
i was really just thinking like because
i was really getting annoyed
i would say for the past two years where
i felt like almost
all podcasters really the the show ended
up being about cancel culture and social
justice what do you mean
that's just all anybody was talking
about for a very long time
about how they're anti-cancer culture
because they're comedians well yeah just
like the sensitivity online but it
literally became such
a topic that it was just like it's a
self-fulfilling thing because like
everybody was always talking about just
how sensitive people are online and
not you gotcha but oh i can go on all
day but it's repetitive after the
pandemic now
i would really just in my own mind like
to think that that's going to like fade
away people have real problems to worry
about
it's not even that it's like if you do
not [__] with it you don't gotta be here
just like this if you don't like action
movies don't go to the [__] action
movie
simple as that you think your children
should be watching family guys like
cusses
where the [__] are you when they turned
it on that's it
if you don't like some [__] don't
support it put it this way
i say this celebrity you just [__]
hate because you're a weirdo say there's
a celebrity you hate
and you go on their page you look at
their page like i [__] hate this
[__]
god he's doing so good why full sucks or
whatever the [__]
don't look at it in one week's time it's
like they are never there
and that's what you got to do with the
[__] that you don't like whoever the
[__] got
dr seuss cancelled i want you to go to
your grave knowing you [__] it up for
everybody
dr seuss is awesome i don't know what
books are racist and [__] then again
i was a kid i probably wouldn't pick
that up i don't know i told you probably
some super racist [__]
[__] look at miguel jump over the wall
it's literally just slurs
you know what maybe i don't know maybe
it's we should have looked into this we
still look to do it more
but all i gotta say is if you don't like
the [__] book don't read it
and like i said earlier they're
canceling dr seuss when mein kampf
is a book you can still get written by
adolf hitler
let's just stop right there let's stop
right there before i get upset yeah
blazing saddles that's it right there
with gene wilder
very good movie i watched that my uncle
john showed me that when i was
like 12. so do they have a couple
different kinds of racism going on in
here just based on this
pictures just you ever heard that [__]
in a lot of rappers uh like samples
where all the white women at
that's it that's where this is from it's
so [__] good it's the most
racist [__] dude but
every one of those comedians read that
script and went nah this is funny
because it is then again it's different
types of uh humor i love offensive [__]
i love offensive [__] because it's so
shocking and i go
hey good job to you for [__] having
the balls to say that [__]
because it's funny and to me i like i
told marty before i
love racist jokes and [__] when they're
poking fun at people's races because
we're all human the only we're the same
inside with the same
everything except for what the way we
look [__] talk about fat people
all day where the [__] are you guys
talking [__] to people talk about i'm
[__] fat but i don't give a [__] make
fun of fat people that's
funny make dude as long as you're making
[__] laugh and it's not
literally hey
you know what i don't like black guys
let's go find a black guy and kill like
that it's a [__] hate speech as long
as your
jokes aren't turning into hate speech on
some cartman [__]
then it's it's different it's true
though because nobody gets mad at dave
chappelle when he's making fun of white
people
why because it's [__] hysterical it's
hysterical
the best person to ever talk about
things like this is george carlin to me
that [__] was so open book going
hey
don't be [__] stupid or you're this
and that's all that's all it ever is are
you [__] stupid
that's it marty if you have to ask
yourself that am i [__]
you're [__] stupid if you have to
stop and ask yourself
you're the others okay i was going to
say i feel like i've asked myself that
before
no no i'm talking about in terms of
dave chappelle you can't say that that's
racist what about white people that talk
like that but then don't watch it
the [__] but the one thing that kind of
irks me a little bit when people attack
white
comedians for saying certain things hey
man it's comedy
close your eyes pretend he's not white
is it funny all right then then
we're back we're back we're not there we
have to be what you would think i'm
gonna
i'm gonna try my best to make it okay
because i look
white to some [__] but i'm not
rosie's grandma thought i was white
the whole time i knew her so the day she
[__] passed away she thought i was
white
i swear to god dude a lot of people do
but um i mean my whole family's white i
feel like i understood this principle as
a small child
i feel like i just like dark humor just
humor just dark humor
going for what's funniest it's funny
shockful
you are actually inherently just a nice
person so that gives you the leeway to
just go for the funny
i see what you're saying like wait but
he looks so nice did he just say some
racist joke
i did i did was it funny it was funny
but i'm offended
hey man i'll take that first part a
little bit bigger than the offensive
part
it was funny is all i cared about um
so yeah doc that all stamped marty from
dr seuss books getting cancelled we're
getting censored too but
i mean one day they'll like drug stories
[__] i always think back on this guys
every time i people ask me about story
times or [__] like that
i always got to remember what story time
oh yeah
i forgot that was me and i did that in
life
every time i go back to my hometown i
think of that [__] like oh my god that's
exactly where that [__] happened
and then one day it's going to be a
movie i can we're turning story times
into a movie
it's not just it doesn't even have to be
us we'll just write a [__] move super
bad
was seth rogan's uh uh weekend in high
school
um so i think that that's why so joan
hill was named seth
it was just a weekend in high school
hold on you're blowing my mind here i
didn't realize that yeah
it's just that's how he got the that's
how he got the um
the idea for that movie and he was older
not to play the high school so he played
the cop
[Music]
bomb that's bomb [__] that's like on
undeclared wasn't the way no no no no
freaks and geeks when he was in freaks
and geeks when they were in high school
with james for that was a good ass show
it just ended
another good show that just stopped i
felt like so many good shows just got
cut short
amer arrested development got cut short
freaks and geeks got cut short bernie
mac got cut short
i i don't know man i don't know but
that's why i bring that up the josh
wolfe show
josh wolfe show that his face when we
brought it up he went
the josh joshua he was so hyped on i
loved that dude
you could tell on this honest that
little kid
that's what we all strive to get we all
want that feeling
from what we're doing um so yeah [__] dr
seuss
so here we go guys uh another thing i've
been seeing
and do you know what deep fake is marty
i like to think i'm the original deep
faker
what do you mean listen you're looking
at the original face swapper
photoshop podcast and graphic designer
in here okay
oh that's right that's right
you should do all those flipped graphics
for like with fire and the kids yeah we
were the first ones to do it but there
were pet they weren't like deep
fake videos like it is now no no i get
what you're saying you're face swapping
all their faces for different [__]
that's that's funny you were doing that
like five years ago and i was doing that
and pictures where i wasn't really there
it's the same like thing to think it's
funny that we're doing that [__]
at the same time yeah i've considered
that it's pretty tight
i used to put my like put myself in
pictures like on stage with the beatles
you're like wait
how old are you you know some people
think that shit's real and then i feel
are you one of the people that have to
ask am i [__] stupid
you're stupid that'll concern you like
it's like one of those like uh things
where you look at the van's shoe
and some people see pink some people see
blue type of thing people ask i didn't
get that when people did the dress the
blue and the
it just concerns me because it's like
all right there's a bunch of people out
there that are clearly not seeing these
graphics as i'm making them
yeah dude um i'm sorry well then again
if
you're not one of these people because
if you are one of these people you
wouldn't understand what i'm saying
there's a lot of stupid [__]
out there i mean
there's a lot of really really stupid
people
the average child is really simple it
shocks me it makes me sad and it makes
me scared and it makes me scared for
their parents
and their kids coming in the future
because they have to get raised by those
[__] but then again my mom and
dad barely raised my ass
so it doesn't really matter who your
parents are when i'm making graphics or
you know projects that are going out to
a lot of people i try to think about it
as if like a three to four year old
would really understand it
that's how you resonate good with the
general mass
public like the obvious explain to the
over budget to me like i'm five yeah
explaining to me like i'm five
yeah yeah i'll really have my kids come
out like when my
my kids come out and you ask him do you
get this yeah totally so if emery's like
oh i get it
the older ones but yeah really they've
i've had
i've been out there working for weeks on
a project my uh 12 year old will come
out and be like uh that's
like say one little thing in passing and
you're like and she's completely right
and it changes the course of the whole
project this happened
50 times that's kind of tight it is
that's cool you have a bunch of
different eyeballs from different age
ranges yeah but they know what the
average person's gonna like if it's too
detailed if there's too much
yeah if it's too much of a reference to
something like there's a certain level
of just
on par for the general this is my thing
i like to do things where only like five
people get it
uh-huh yeah i feel like yo for the u5 it
was made your whole day
you know like when i did the reservoir
dogs i did a picture of a i had many
chairs i was for a long time i was
finding mini stuff at stores
i had a mini wooden chair and hempwick
the [__] that's usually on my lighter
that i light my bong with
i got a nug and i put him sitting
on the chair and tied him up like like
it was rope but it was just hemp wig and
then
in pictures before instagram had video
and pictures of one frame two frame
three frame
i had another guy nugg walking up and i
had a mini pair of scissors
i was reenacting the reservoir dogs when
he chops when he slices marvin nash's
ear off
and in it there's like he's walking up
with a knife
and you can see and from a different
angle now there's just a chunk missing
off the nug's head
so and then he comes back and he's hello
can you hear me
just like that i mean i if i didn't put
the description
only a handful of people are going to
get that and that's what i want uh-huh i
want that
uh i want to be in a crowded room of a
bunch of people and i hear
in the back yeah that one guy
but that's not the way to be you have to
appeal to the masses if you want that
[__] to work
but still um i get what you're saying
one person says something
but like now you you have such a big
community now that it's just like it's a
million people but they're all those
people
thank you they're all the people in the
back
[Laughter]
exactly dude um i love our fans of the
[__]
yeah i have a very unique experience in
terms of working with a lot of different
people with big fan bases
and seeing the reaction from their fans
being cognizant of it when things are
dropping over the years and i've never
seen anything like it for sure
it's unbelievable huh yeah it really is
because they're
they're not only just fans of you but
they're rooting for you because they
know you as a person they know your
story they've been following most of
your fans been following you forever
they watch the entirety of what you put
out they're excited for it i mean
just the way i would be if i follow
somebody yeah i mean it's it's cool to
find a bunch of people like us
yeah it's really exactly what it is a
bunch of people that we would be like
that changed my life like when rogan
first came out that
single-handedly changed my life probably
kept me out of jail kept me out of a ton
of [__] because it's like
oh these are who i'm actually like yep
and they're successful
exactly and they can do it and they've
done it yeah
a hundred percent like when i was a kid
and everyone's laughing at chris farley
i thought like
yo this fat guy making everybody laugh
he can do it like if he can do it i'm
pretty sure i could do that
i used to be extreme physical comedy
when i was a kid
i would land on my [__] face if it
made it funnier
i used to do a bunch of i used to do the
uh
um the pans the cookie sheets
over the head because when my friends
would come over they'd like oh my god
and then they'd laugh when they realized
i was i was okay yeah
i don't know what it was i would just do
stupid [__] i'd jump off the jungle gym
and land flat
and quote [__] uh the mask look mom
roadkill i would do that [__]
all the time because people would be
like oh my god
and they start laughing i just thought
it was fun like everyone's laughing
all right my job is done i'm out there
i'm on the original track in my work
oh the original jackass i think everyone
was the original jackass
everyone as kids was jumping into bushes
and doing stupid [__] but when it came
out
everyone and their mom started jumping
into bushes and doing stupid [__]
because i wasn't that wild man i wasn't
doing [__] like
i really really love jack this is crazy
why we got in this topic but jackass
i there's there's been like five shows i
happen to walk in and it's the world
premiere
premiering new episode remember remember
those like first episode pilot series or
all that [__]
yeah i'd have the mtv the globe yep
spinning i walked in and it was johnny
knoxville i didn't know i was just
getting out with a
tall guy and he was on rollerblades
trying to jump
a little canal and he broke his ankle
and i remember thinking
yo he just broke his ankle on tv
show is this we were so simple then
we were so simple you had never seen
anything now it's
oh what compilation now one five minute
compilation on youtube is jackass series
yeah
that's something i scroll by as i'm
walking around the house
yep another guy jumping off
but when it came out it's because they
were the first to do it on a global
scale
i mean when they came i had the jackass
shirt the [__] uh
skulls with the american flag the skull
and crossbones on the american flag and
it said jackass this big mtv on the back
of the shirt
and i remember every single time because
i you can't wear something that says
jackass to school
i was in the six [__] grade so i
remember when teachers walk by do this
one
and they walk by i hold my backpack a
little tighter and higher
so it'd go up and cover the jackass logo
on the back and i just
and when the teacher would be in class a
turn oh yeah so
yep yep all right
just trying to hide that [__] i wore so
much stupid [__] as a kid i'm surprised
i got
i got away with it i wear a lot of skate
[__] that was like a little
a little edgy i used to wear a lot of uh
random [__] from frisco because my mom
would always go to san francisco
i'd find cool [__] but um did you guys
have the whole era of jinko jeans and
all that i've heard of jinko jeans but
i was poor it doesn't matter i mean
we're talking about just the 90s thing i
don't know what they were
they were like [__] bell bottoms
basically with a striped on the side of
them ew that's what those are my sister
used to rock that [__] yeah
i mean yeah they're like i think she
made those icp styles
yeah okay so my sister was a [__] she
used to have the liberty spikes
the big uh oh god my sister used to
[__] beat my ass guys yeah
she saw the big liberty spike she was
like in a punk hella she was always
uh gluing [__] to her clothes and and
just
pins and putting pins in her [__]
eyebrows and
that she was there liberty spikes right
there so my sister's when rosie first
when me and rosie first started hanging
out and she saw her my sister is my
sister and when she left she goes
is that the girl used to have the really
big spikes at my yes my sister she's a
dick
and now she's cool but yeah my sister
used to have all that [__]
anyway back to jackass when i first saw
that it blew my [__] mind
i fell in love with all those fools and
then about
14 to 15 is when i got introduced to cky
do you know what cky is marty no cky is
bam
ryan dunn rabb himself brian d camillo
raykeon jackass the little group of they
were doing that [__] at like 12
13. and what happened is johnny
knoxville and jeff germain
found them i think that's how the story
goes they saw them or like yo these guys
have been doing that because cky had a
huge fan base bam was a pro skater like
[__] 17
16. bam is such a bad ass
[__] skateboarder and like you guys
know in story times
i used to skate my whole life and i
stopped like a year or two before i saw
jackass so ryan and ethan when all those
fools were
we're all doing drugs and getting [__]
up we watched cky
because we loved that [__] cky is the
ultima remember we talked about white
guy stuff marty in the first episode
that's why guy's [__] [__] slapping
you in the dick that is cky man
that is the epitome of of white boy frat
[__]
nice and it's great i love it
but when that [__] came out dude that
was everything to me
it was everything and now stephen got a
[__] we got to get stevo on the [__]
podcast
you know how bomb that would be you know
how much it's that's
20 years of knowledge of steve all i
have in my head you probably remember
more [__] about his career
than he does for sure for sure just
because i know he was talking about the
drugs and all that kind of [__] him up
i remember everything i remember when he
did the elephant back flip [__] into
this [__]
that's the one that was first i think
that was first or second episode i know
he regurgitated that
uh goldfish and i uh you know when you
not when you throw up in your mouth but
you get like that puke
taste that happened when i first saw the
goldfish thing and i were thinking oh
that guy steve was [__] nasty yeah
yeah he was the first one to stretch
beyond that he was bro
in the movie i can't do that i fast
forward it every time i watch do you
remember that one
uh no he put a real real fish hook that
they they fish would like try to catch
sharks
he put that [__] through his cheek and
then jumped into shark water
with a bleeding cheek no [__] that
[__] and then the shark was coming
for him and he was trying to swim away
and he accidentally kicked in the nose
and it took off
and i don't think i don't even think he
saw the shark right then in there if he
didn't do that he got bit by a shark
uh no thanks no [__] thing i feel
like things like i would get so [__]
up so quickly
like i like i don't know how how many
shark attack victims watched that like
the shark just swam away from this fight
some people just dodged some people just
dodge all the
death they dodged the death and then
people just over here getting [__]
hit by icicles and dying death dodgers
there's a new podcast for you
damn death dodgers final destination
six um sorry guys we got off topic there
my bad that was all stem from deep fake
okay guys so where were you originally
going with that
ready marty hey marty do you know what
deep fake is
there you go yeah you know what you're
talking too yeah and then you went
you know the [__] you talking to then it
just got crazy so
this deep fake [__] i thought
jim carrey was redoing a scene from the
shining
and i thought to myself oh he is doing
it movement from
because i have photographic memory i
know exactly on movies how this
motherfucker's moving and talking
and i was thinking he is acting jack
nicholson more than jack nicholson right
now
and as he was getting up like yo jim
carrey they did a great job
on making him look like jack nicholson
in the shining and then i found out it
was deep fake
so for all you out there that don't know
what deep fake is like i didn't
d fake is the most it's the scariest and
most detrimental thing to the [__]
human population that's ever happened
right now if i go beat someone's ass on
the street
i can make it look like you beat
someone's ass on the street
they can take your face and put it on
someone's face and it
is so it's indistinguishable it is so
[__] scary you have no idea i could
be having a facetime conversation with
[__] tom hanks and think it's [__]
tom hanks
and it could be just a voice actor and a
random guy it's scary marty
you've seen it it makes me feel like a
shitty graphic artist because yeah
too much hold on hey deanna rosie you
guys seen david
marty i feel like a piece of [__] no man
i'm talking about that deep fake [__] is
so
real i can't tell it apart and i don't
like that that's that's the thing for me
i don't like that my brain can't say
that's the fake one
yeah you're not supposed to [__] with
reality yeah it's [__] with your
actual perception
and i don't oh how many how long has
that been around you know i'm saying did
mike
mike tyson did you really buy him in the
ear or was it somebody else you know
what i mean like
you could it could be that old it could
be that [__] old dude
to where someone's been faking a whole
[__] career off that [__] mm-hmm i
mean think about it dude
if they could do that can they do that
live
uh eventually right could they do a
little [__] chip
under your hair that puts a little oh
yeah oh for sure a screen over your face
that's what i'm saying like damn my
title was that even you
because dude think about that right now
what was it uh
uh what was i listening to the other day
oh i was in joe rogan podcast
i'm just gonna say this right now
freddie gibbs is the funniest [__]
rapper on the planet
he's the funniest [__] of all
time that
man makes me crack the [__] up and then
you have to remember
oh this is freddy gibbs hard ass rapping
ass freddie get
[__] that motherfucker's tight and you
know did you listen to the episode it
was four
hours long okay yo
this fool was talking about how mf doom
talked about
he used to send somebody in a mask when
he didn't want to go to perform in the
shows
he would just send somebody pay somebody
to wear a mask and do the show
because he always wears a [__] mask
so that's why i bring him to deep fake
how long have we been able to
fake that kind of [__] can you do it
live
you know what i'm saying like did you
see that little that guy that pretended
to be a little pump and got all the way
on stage as a little pump
hmm i don't know about that he he just
dressed like him bro that's all he did
have a couple security guards and people
taking pictures
these fools let him straight into the
vip section all that [__] to the stage
and it wasn't even him so if that little
glimpse can
make 500 people in that club go oh my
god it is a little pump
what's this deep fake [__] going to do
to us get us into wars and show
thank you thank you sir [__] just like
that
hey country this is us pissing on your
flag
president president united states no
hell no that's not fair
i want i want to be able to you can't
see you can't believe anything unless
you see it in person touch it now
you know what i'm saying but even still
i mean you got a little pump walking
around those fools
i know and touch and like be up there
and be you know what then again there's
look alikes you know what
i'm just gonna stay at my house man i'm
just gonna stay at my house and like we
said
we're not creeps we're not perverts
me and marty are just chilling so one
day when we get rich as [__] please
best believe you ain't not gonna see
jurassic graphics and dope as usual
we're chest bumping underage girls and
[__] you know
giving knuckles and [__] i feel like i
have we
me and you have extra authority to speak
on this [__] because you're one of the
only people that i know
aside from myself that genuinely signed
up for like a monogamous relationship at
a young age and stuck to it
yes i i knew when i was doing it i was
21. i'm like i know what i'm signing up
for you know this is a special situation
i'm not gonna
slap it in the face but i don't really
know anybody else in that boat
i i know some i know some people but i
don't know rosie and i
when we started dating we didn't think i
mean
you don't think of like where are we
gonna be in five years you're just
dating somebody
no i was the first different you got
married and had a child and you said
the moment i met april i knew that was
it i get what you mean because i
remember
it was day four and rosie i remember the
day i was like oh yeah this is the
person i'm gonna chill with forever
it's like day four i remember that yeah
something like that yeah
i almost ruined it with april off the
bat too because you were still dating
another human being you mean
but even then i was a g about it because
i told you i told her right
that was inadvertently the strongest
game i could have did because they're
real they're even stronger but she was a
g ladder because she
was like uh okay that's fine we'll just
be friends we'll just hang out
stronger
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was true oh you told me the story
you this man
i love you first day basically and goes
but i'm dating another human so let's
just be friends
you're a wild [__] uh
something like that wait speak tell us
listen i was with a girl that i thought
i was going to be with because she was a
singer she had a [__] her [__] together
she had a house
you know this is unheard of out you know
way
far away from where i lived but yeah
that didn't work out but as that was not
working out is when i came into contact
with april so there was this gray area
where i was in both
all the all the dudes i know would have
not even
gave that a second thought that i had
kids with all the girls they could have
had kids with
but yeah i let her know right away like
because we hung out once or twice and
then i was just like you know what i'm
not gonna
mess with like play around with your
emotions like this i'm still
halfway in this other relationship like
it's not gonna happen i
i was so dead focused on music too i was
just like yeah but then the more i
thought about it like
all my friends had babies mamas and all
this drama and [__]
i was really putting out there to the
universe like i want something solid
i want that i want that situation and
then when it came to me and then i
realized it came to me it's like other
things in life where you're like [__] i
asked for this and it came to me now i
gotta
really treat it with some [__]
respect that's how i thought about it
like it'd be a slap in the face to
whatever force is out there brought me
this situation
because especially once you add kids in
the equation and [__]
damn marty you just broke down life
you just hear this right now there's so
many fools going
yeah yeah right now with all their
homies looking around like
you guys are all the people he's talking
about yeah i don't feel like people
cheering me on because i signed up for
zoom no
unique [__] so unique
you did you you basically did military
life minus the military
you did exactly what military people do
like yo
i like you married kids life
life except you're like you know what
i'm doing this rap [__] right now
i don't think i like you what a way that
was hard
i like the way you put that yeah no
i didn't even know what i was doing i
didn't know that that was the effect but
it was
it had that effect but then that's what
a g april is
so follow me now the girl that i was
dating prior to her i was basically
living at her condo
she was a singer we had done some songs
together okay
wait marty you impressed this girl so
hard with your lyrics you she
she moved you in yes
wait we can't see your face let's see
what you guys could see
yes that was the most confident thing
i've ever heard besides hey you want to
focus this camera
yes i'm more confident in that first one
than the camera focus
oh my god no you gotta understand
because she moved you into her condom
literally though she had a boyfriend
okay
she i had a girlfriend at the time okay
listen to how messed up this is i didn't
really like the girl that i was with at
the time
the singer no this was a different girl
so i'm hoping
kevin fetterline no listen this sounds
the sounds bigger and better
okay please keep going this is a string
of events it's not glamorous
all right so i was with this girl i just
i knew i didn't like this one girl i was
with
okay whatever like so valentine's day is
rolling around and i'm like what am i
gonna get her for valentine's day
the same girl that you don't like you
said what am i gonna get have you ever
watched the office
no you're ryan i keep going all right so
i'm like all right
twofer i'm gonna make her a song okay
it's valentine's day i'm gonna get a new
song out of this i was recording heavy
i'm in the studio three times a week at
this point
so then this other girl i had already
been having my eye on her because she
was a big singer in buffalo
so then i reached out to her hey you
want to collaborate i want to do a song
so then i go over to her house her
boyfriend's their families her kind of
all this [__] i meet her
that basically probably that next day i
think she had already made up in her
mind like all right i'm getting rid of
this dude i'm with i was like
we by valentine's day me and her were a
couple
okay so for everyone in the car that's
dying laughing
you can't pay attention marty's with the
girl and he goes
nah she's okay don't really like her let
me get rid of her soon
valentine's day coming up can't be a
dick let me get her something
it's cool you're a nice guy and then you
go hey girl
other girl i kind of like you but can we
make a song together for my girlfriend
so she'll be really happy i didn't know
i liked her yet
and then you oh you didn't really like
yourself you wouldn't ever makes a song
with this girl and goes hey
i like you the song we're making for my
girlfriend's now for you
and then she goes damn this
[__] lyrics are so damn
hard i'm kicking my boyfriend out
tomorrow and in two days i'm gonna be
dating this [__] with the lyrics
and then you they both got did that her
boyfriend and your girlfriend get
together because i would admit i was
like yo you guys should meet
cause you guys both get [__]
yo marty that was the most scandalous
[__]
but i wasn't even i let the girl know
though like i didn't string her along no
it's not like you were it was
like [__] if we just write this on paper
and what you did with bullet points it
sounds bad damn mario
damn marty so let me keep going here so
yeah so then i'm with this girl for
about two months she has her own singers
yeah she had her and you moved in mm-hmm
because she's a [__] baller basically
no because i didn't have anything i'm
saying
you're a baller in the terms of talking
i'm a baller in terms of having all my
[__] in a garbage bag basically
yo marty stop
yo we gotta show the picture barney sent
me sorry to interrupt marty sent me a
picture the other day i go what rap what
group is this
and i look in the cycle is that [__]
marty with nine dudes wearing the same
matching shirt
holy [__] that place looks rough and
there's marty on the side
so i'm gonna [__] spawn on all you
[__]
sorry continue she kicked her boyfriend
out you moved in basically because
you're a baller with your words
yeah and she goes hey you need to move
in did you hold on did you write any
songs for her
yes oh there you go she was like yeah
okay that's where the story is going
that song that i was going to make for
my original girlfriend turned into like
my best song i ever made
like my some of my friends got played at
weddings
it was a cool song it was called it was
a good song so we recorded it
all right it got played at weddings in
buffalo uh-huh
yo on the radio yeah on the radio your
song oh that's bomb
did you have a oh yeah you did he have a
straight cut with a diamond stud
that's what i'm imagining the uh with
the chin strap and all that
man listen they would i would go to
barber shops
in like the neighborhood and [__] and
they would not know like they wouldn't
have a pair of scissors i remember this
was a joke
like it's a long story anyway yeah i
used to have those haircuts and [__]
anyway yeah so keep going this went on
for a couple months we made this song
was my best song we did a couple songs i
wasn't i thought i was about to really
i wasn't that was in the hit my real
[__] like heyday of
really coming super close to big time
record deals that was
in that whole era and this is when you
moved out here but yeah right this is
before that
this is a couple years even before that
oh damn so uh
yeah so then we um she just had a lot of
like
i don't know a lot of unresolved stuff
kids that age especially out of buffalo
you have so many [__] issues how old
are you 19
20 yeah 19 20 21 her dad died that was
the reason she had the condos she had
gone through a bunch of [__]
so she just had you know a bunch of
unresolved stuff going on that didn't
you know
it started like not working out but as
as that was happening
is when like me and april were getting
and she was my space she messaged me on
myspace
she she saw my pictures at the g unit
office i think is what it was
[Laughter]
i think the g unit pictures got her and
then she actually started
yeah she sent me a message of me yeah
that was the first one
and then uh i remember i left i left
from
from that the singer's house i went to
april's apartment and
[__] seneca and princeton for
everybody in buffalo
so when uh you she messaged you on
myspace and said yo
want a high five basically and you went
over there
so you already didn't like this other
girl anymore i had already i was already
mine you were done
i was keeping my options open after that
at that point because she had really
like
i was like i saw how my whole life could
go in that moment like oh [__]
i'm out of lackawanna she's out in like
the the richest nicest part of town
she's got her [__] together she's going
to college like i could totally see how
this is going to go
gotcha and then you're making music
together yeah exactly yeah okay
i get it you thought it was gonna be
dope as [__] and then you realize
yo this girl's crazy you don't want to
say it like that no i'm not even i'm
saying that for the girl that's
listening
okay he did go like this
but you know like no not at all there's
a camera on you man
i'm lying i'm a liar but um so you met
april because she said yo that's high
five and chess bump mm-hmm
yeah i'm out of april and then started
bringing her around all my friends all
my friends
loved my other girlfriend too because we
were all in music and she was like the
biggest singer in town so she knew all
my friends she had been
hanging out with us and [__] and it's
small and it's super small yeah so
yeah so anyway about a year after i had
been with april
i wanted to re-record that song because
it was one of my best songs and now i
was in real studios and i wanted to have
it redone and join and really do it mix
and master it
and i was like all right i'm gonna
rewrite it i'll get a new singer we'll
go in there and figure it out it's gonna
be awesome and she's like no
get her have her come and do it april
said that yeah
don't change any other words don't
change anything have her come in and
redo it
did you do that yeah oh [__] the girl
was down to record with you after you
dumped the rest yeah cause did you
dunk on her when you left i did oh what
did you do
yeah i did what'd you do when you left
because we were walking out
we were walking out in that year i had
gotten my [__] together
in that year because now it was two of
us it was me and april i had gotten my
[__] together to the point that i had
a nice car i had things going on so i
was like
she was like as we're walking out like
i'm so
i didn't really consider your feelings
and i'm i was i had so much going on i'm
sorry so this is during a fight and
she's being addicted to you
this was as we're walking out of the
studio she starts saying this oh
like going back because it was all just
wait are you talking about when she saw
oh because you
got you i'm talking about when you broke
up with her originally
there wasn't even a clean oh she it was
unresolved
yeah it was basically december i've
never broken up with anybody so i had no
idea
it was uh yeah it was just a you know
fallback basically i guess but anyway
she was like she apologized and [__] and
i was like
oh no it is okay listen everything is
[__]
perfect like it's fine trust me it is
fine
and then you and one juke direction as
you got into your [__] 300 yeah
exactly
yeah pop that master in and uh
yeah that was it though april was a g
for that one right she's like no
the girl you left for me i want you to
go record with her by yourself
go re-record the song for her with her
with oh
there my god how terrible
marty repurposed this song and snagged
two girls three
three snack three damn
he's batting a thousand more yeah yeah
you gotta make those studio hours count
they're expensive
you use it as a [__] christmas and
valentine's day present
and studio tour yo you are good
you're uh why do we keep bringing day
spell up you literally just
no thank you and took the money from the
bum right now
that's the [__] you did have baked yeah
yeah yo
that was a good i've never heard that
part of the story that was good i loved
it
so we get from that whole situation that
marty's nice guy
doing scandalous scandalous things none
of the girls i ever
dealt with in life would say a bad thing
about me
you're a nice guy yeah and then you just
[__] double pumped him and [__]
laughed yeah i mean [__] how was in
those years you're trying to figure it
out you know i wasn't like i had my
couple years of
like you know just messing with a bunch
of girls and [__] but i knew by the time
i was 19 or 20 i
like knew in my head i want one solid
girl i said it out loud
i remember literally we were riding in
the car and i like described the girl i
wanted it was
you were in the car with who with my
boys okay
i remember because he looked at me crazy
i was like
this sounds [__] stupid but i was
like you dumb you got money right now
you're
rapping you're trying to get one girl
that wasn't yeah that's literally what
your friends were saying i was
yeah i was a starving artist oh okay
okay we
you know there was a bunch of i was like
i want like a hood ass white girl is
what i said it sounds [__] stupid you
literally just
that's what i said i was like and then
my friend next to me looks at me he's
like uh yeah no [__]
you're like i want a me but a girl
i was dating all these like randoms you
know that
i was just like i was like thinking of
eight mile i want the girl he had an
eight mile she was down for him like she
was [__]
yo marty get the [__] out of here
and then literally oh god you fast
forward a month later
fast forward two months beyond that and
we got a [__] family it was like have
right
and but it would all happen within
months
yeah oh man like we got together
i stayed over at her apartment and that
was it i live here now like
we're together we're married got a habit
of that yeah stayed in that girl's house
you go hey guy
you gotta you gotta go
you want me to wrap you out the door
[__] you gotta go our first uh
hook first apartment was a [__] if
you like i'm talking about
infested like her aunt her april's aunt
was like
lived there for a while too she was
didn't want to be there didn't want to
live there
the first night that she lived first
night she was there somebody threw a
brick through her windshield
just randomly wake up with a brick
through your windshield and you know
what sucks if something's under your car
you don't know if it's personal mm-hmm
you don't know if that's a grudge coming
back again
it's gonna be your head next time you're
just like damn man
who the [__] did i play or if it's just
completely random
yeah uh i don't know how the [__] we got
on that topic guys but
let's get on to this next topic which is
almost the same [__] topic
okay so updated news and life
all right you guys already know rosie
and i
rosie we have been dating for nine years
going on ten years
all right it's [__] weird to say out
loud
super [__] weird to say out loud
anyway
so this guy right here all these
podcasts you've been watching i've been
in a little devious [__]
and been planning some [__] and this
last saturday
and what's today wednesday a couple days
ago guys
um i finally i did what i was gonna do
and me and rosie are now engaged i
proposed to rosie on saturday
it wasn't even a proposal it was like
hey [__] i know the answer
but here's a ring that's pretty much how
it went i
asked her do i need to ask
she said shut the f she's all shut up
and then i put the ring on it like
i didn't need to ask i did not need to
ask i already knew the answer
it was more of hey
i did it are you ready because we always
talk about it we talk we've been
together for nine years
we talk about getting married like i'm
not in a rush i'm not going anywhere
you're not going anywhere
we're both busy whenever happens it
happens but for everyone out there
that's been following for a long time
yes rosie and i are now engaged she's no
longer my girlfriend
no longer my girlfriend which is weird
weird to think about
that's crazy it's such a trip guys it's
[__] insane to think about it but
yeah i've been planning this [__] for a
long ass time
and i finally got around to do it
because i needed it i needed all the
circumstances to work out right
you know i need my plan was to do it
this is what this is what my plan was my
plan was
i was gonna have my uncle john but
obviously you guys know he passed away
i talked to him in last year and
summertime
and he passed away like a month after i
told him like
we had a plan right we had a plan to
like make that doesn't make the house
look like it did when we first met so
when we first met was at the push trees
house on 27th streets and merced
so since pandemic's been happening and
we haven't really been going to merced
i knew i was going to propose there i've
been playing this [__] for like [__]
a long
this has been a long time coming anyway
it worked out
uh i recorded i've been i had rosie
thinking we're recording another vlog
for a whole week but little does she
know i was recording her and would she
turn around
i'd look at the camera like like she has
no idea
that she was recording her own video so
that's what i had going we went down to
merced i didn't sleep last week
every [__] night i was just thinking
like oh my god i wish i could just fast
forward days right now because i just
want to get i just want to go to merced
and do this [__] already because
i didn't want her to find the ring every
day was stressful we live in the same
house and thought like
why is she going to randomly go to need
one of my shoe boxes but i thought she
was gonna
find the ring oh what the [__] is this i
just thought that it was gonna get
ruined and i've been planning for so
long so i was up
all [__] night til four or five in
the morning every night last night uh
last week
i went and got the ring with my friend
shout out to peter marco
peter marco and rodeo right peter marco
radel that's where i got the ring uh my
friend john took me down there
peter marco is super [__] cool he
kind of reminds me of sam kinnison
he's just ah he's got a loud
super cool guy but he was anyway
super cool guy we got the ring we are
now engaged for everyone out there
and i want to tell you guys a little
story because people ask me all the
[__] time when are you getting
married when are you getting married and
the other thing is how did you guys meet
so today i want to tell you guys a
little story i'll make it i'll make it
quick
i won't go elaborate but i'll tell you
guys how
rosie and i met so we've been dating for
nine years going on 10 years
um we met on
11 11 12 11.
right no 11 11
20 22. yeah it's 11 11 it's 11
22 11. november 22nd 2011. this is such
a sick ass [__] combination one one
two two one one
that's the day we started dating so my
high ass just stuttered my way through
numbers right now rosie what the
[__] for everyone wondering why i'm
looking that way rosie's right there
so this is how we met guys i you guys
know that i didn't do
i didn't do school i
uh my last senior year was not a good
year for me okay i didn't show up
so we had a class called cap that we go
hang out with like an elementary kid
show them dodge ball basketball you know
that you get on the bus go to elementary
you do one period you leave
so i met rosie on the app oh i didn't
meet rosie that bus i saw her on that
bus
that's it i knew that that was rosie i
had nothing else i didn't go to school i
didn't talk to anybody i knew people i
talked to and that was it
i from her perspective i was a guy that
was just high on drugs or whatever and
sold drugs
that's it that was that guy in class and
i never showed up that's one thing she
said you know you just never showed up
to class anyway fast forward
i'm 21 i'm 21 years old and
i sell weed obviously and the only
reason i go to bars is so i can drink a
little bit with my friends but sell weed
to people
people at bars will just buy weed do you
understand what i'm saying
people at bars and they want to smoke
right now we'll give you
40 dollars for a dub they'll give you
anything you can skip those
[__] if you want i didn't
but it was more of oh yeah you mean 20
here here it is gone
here it is gone and i would sell like a
[__] half zip to a zip and i get to
chill with my friends
all my shits are free basically because
i just bought it with the weed money
that i was sitting there making
what's up guys before we get into this
love story i want to tell you guys about
ball stuff i'm trying to think of a
better way to do it
let's talk about your dick
all right that's what i'm gonna do hey
what's up guys i hope you're enjoying
this episode this is uh
how i fell in love with my girlfriend
episode and before we get into all the
soft stuff
let's talk about your balls yes guys
this episode is sponsored by manscaped
if you don't know what manscaped is
here's the uh family-friendly pitch
this is a a groomer for your nether
regions below the belt
keep yourself trimmed don't look gross
now for the r type of ad read this
is to trim your balls this is to trim
your pubic hair don't look like a nasty
[__] when you go out and you meet some
girl and you come back and she goes
i'm going to [__] leave that would be
the most embarrassing thing on the
[__] planet
all right manscaped has everything they
got cologne they got [__] wipes and
when i say wipes you know girls have
feminine wipes
these are wipes for your balls and i'm
not kidding they're
called ball wipes manscapes advertising
is [__] amazing
it literally plays to anybody that has a
sense of humor and it's not approved if
you want to get your own landscape
products go to www.manscape.com but use
code yola if you use code yolo you get
off and free shipping don't pay the
[__] shipping fees just use code yola
at checkout
if you saw our ad read last week we
definitely didn't show our dicks but we
did show
how to use manscaped how to trim it up
it worked i had a professional barber
come over and he goes yo these are
really good and i said
good because it's our sponsor we've
almost cut our dick off we've almost cut
our balls off so be safe
use the lawnmower 3.0 it's it's
technologically advanced
not to catch the skin and cut you that's
what it's for it's
it's for your balls so thank you guys so
much for watching this ad read and like
i said if you don't like our ad reads
[__] off so again guys use code yola at
checkout 20 off free shipping
back to the episode
so we're at this bar i walk in and
there's a girl monica i know her from
school
monica's standing right next to rosie i
say you know hello to rosie you know
when you don't know it's a girl you
don't like
hey what up but i did that to monica hey
what's going on and i like chuck rosie's
channel hi how you doing
thomas like i introduced myself guys i'm
polite
so i'm walking around i'm chilling my
friends at the bar i
[__] hate the bar i don't like being
at the bar especially when you're 21
everybody out there right now
if you're 21 to 23 and you're still in
your hometown
you go to a bar it's like going to the
senior circle it's like going back to
the quad it's like chilling at lunch
room in the break
it's the same [__] i ain't
trying to go back and chill with
[__] i didn't
chill with anyway so that's why i don't
really like going to bars like i said i
went so i could sell weed and i chill
with my friends but
this time i'm chilling and like 15
minutes after i get there
rosie comes up to me and she asked me
hey monica said you sell weed
uh can i buy weed from you basically
that's pretty much how she didn't say it
like that that's
she pretty much said like oh monk said
you have weed can i buy weed
and then sorry my high ass is stumbling
over here
and um i looked at her like are you
[__] kidding me
in my head i'm saying like thomas you
[__] [__]
but in reality what i said was the one
[__] night
huh she goes huh the one night i don't
bring weed i'm so sorry i don't have any
[__] weed i didn't bring any weed to
sell
i'm sorry and she's like [__] oh
[__] and monica walks up and then
um they get my phone number get my phone
number
they come by we like think the next day
and
let's say that's march
right we start chilling heavy rosie and
i monica
my roommate we just and some of my
friends come up we're all drink
rosie and i used to drink heavy as [__]
i mean we still smoked
we should drink we should get a handle
of captain morgan that's what we used to
get
whenever we drank and people would split
it we'd drink it but
this is how it happened rosie's cool
[__] she's super awesome that's why i
was like yeah you can come to my house
because i sell [__] drugs i got packs
i have a lot of money i'm not just
letting random people that i
know from high school be in my house
just because she's a girl doesn't mean
she won't set your ass up and get robbed
don't be as
don't be dumb so i didn't know rosie
well i didn't know monica well
but i knew like they weren't bad they
weren't bad people because i don't let
new people in my life i don't let people
even now but back then was way worse so
we're chilling we're hanging out we hang
out like they start turning into hey you
want to smoke
hey you guys trying to hang out you guys
want to chill and it becomes those
friends those friends that just come
over
you know what i'm saying my my best
friend was jebus but my other best
friend at the time was this girl named
randy
that [__] [__] this girl named
randy and she was like my
my other best friend she was cool i went
to call i had hello classes with her we
smoked wheat all the time she was cool
and um after the months go by
rosie monica come over we it's like a
routine they walk in
put our stuff on the table this exact
circle looking table
put our stuff on the table walk in the
kitchen put our [__] in the freezer
you know get cups ready and [__] we're
ready to stop smoking we got the bong
out i have
pounds on pounds so like there's no need
for
for scarce of weed like we're chilling
we're hanging out i got youtube on we're
watching a movie or whatever watching
and i noticed over the course of time
that we'd go to the kitchen blah blah
and everybody would walk back
you know into the living room to go
chill and rosie and i would just be
talking
and you know we just randomly like
talking about something we get lost a
conversation
10 minutes later we walk into the living
room
and then over like the next month every
time we're hanging out i noticed me and
rosie you're in the kitchen for like
30 minutes 40 minutes [__] an hour
two hours we're just standing there
talking we start drinking
smoking weed i'll roll joint like right
it just became
oh everyone's here what's up rosie uh
and it became like me and rosie chillin
not everybody else
and we go oh yeah everybody's in the
living room let's go hang out with them
do you see what i'm trying to say it
became to the point where i noticed like
i
i'm just i'm just here to hang out with
rosie at this point you know nobody else
is here basically
so i realized like oh [__] i like rosie
damn it [__]
all right because i'm thinking about me
is
i don't the girls are not a concern to
me
i was concerned about making money
finishing school
i was put off by girls my whole life i
don't want to really [__] with girls
heavy because i don't want kids
my mom had her for 16 18 my dad was 18
and 20 like they were kids having kids
everybody in my high school is [__]
pregnant there's girls with
there was a daycare what school was it
babe
east campus there's a daycare at east
campus for the students kids
all right let's just put it [__] that
way and if you have kids as a teenager
nothing wrong with that if that's what
you want to do
not me not me friend that's why i just
try to stay away from girls unless they
were cool as [__]
and then i can't because now they're
cool as [__] and do you
you see where i'm going with this i put
i i girls were my last thing i didn't
give a [__]
we went to parties like i don't care you
gotta you want to buy weed
because i got my payment rent like
that's really what it is do you wanna
buy a weed
sick that was it it's all those four you
wanna do drugs
i got cocaine and that was like all we
were doing
and then i was chilling with rosie we're
hanging out
and i realized i like rosie and let's
get into this whole ordeal
i took mushrooms one night and i called
rosie and then i thought it was a dream
and a bunch of weird and i just realized
like no i [__] like rosie this
i really like rosie and then
one night i call her i bought a [__] if
you listen to this dealer story time
john john the dealer i bought a shitload
of sassafras
sassafras is like a like a mdma cousin
it's very melty like it's super like
soup feeling and melt and colors are a
little more vivid
and [__] like that that's that's what
sassafras is
i got like i cannot i always want to say
it's 300 pills but i know it's probably
like 200
the number in my head always fluctuates
i can't really fully remember
i sold about 30. me and rosie ate the
entire bag
so this is how it happened i call rosie
and go yo
so look it now that's getting to the
point where it's like yo i call rosie
instead of my other friends my dude
friends like yo you wanna do some drugs
let's just chill
my intentions were never like let me see
if i can bang rosie nothing
it was never like that because i just
like i thought she was cool
you know what i mean when you have
friends that are girls you use friends
but i liked her also
but i wasn't about to [__] our
friendship up do you see what i'm saying
so we were just hanging out no matter
what i was gonna say [__]
i don't know what i was doing all right
so i called her and said hey i got hella
drugs and she goes what the [__] for
real
because i know she liked xc i loved
ecstasy and she's like for real i go
yeah it's called sassafras my friend
gave it to me but like little
tablets like [__] pez but they were
they looked like
they look like pieces of like plant to
smash together i don't know
they were very weird i got them that
night i sold like 10 to somebody i sold
10 to somebody else
i go home and i got them in two ziploc
bags like
bags like if you dumped pez they're like
that shape
so i'm looking i'm like whoa my friend
told me you're bigger so you're gonna
want to take one
maybe two and wait about an hour and a
half see how you feel
and then take a half then take a half
take a half don't do more in life four
oh he's like yeah they don't have like
math they're in it or anything like that
you're not going to get a crazy
heartbeat you're not going to get all
weird
because a lot of the xc merced was cut
with meth and that [__]
i could taste it let's just say that the
second i eat i go
oh i'm going to be up i'm going to be
awake i know that taste in the back of
my teeth
it's like when you're about to eat candy
and you get that feeling in your teeth
that's how i feel about ecstasy like oh
hell yeah
anyway sorry my drug addict just came
out um
i told rosie yo i got a bunch of [__]
sassafras you want to come over
and she didn't live she lived in the
apartment
of my best friend used to the ex my best
friend
all through high school he lit well a
couple years in high school he lived in
this apartment
i remember when you spilled bong water
and the stain on the carpet i walked in
rosie lives in the same [__]
apartment the same egg not apartment
complex the same apartment
so one and it was next door to my best
friend when i was growing up my
other best friend girl it was so weird
queen circle merced
anyway i walk in i go
this is anthony's apartment it's like is
there a
is there a brown stain in the back room
she goes what she was i was wondering
what that stain was and that was her
room
so the room i used to box with my friend
smoke weed in is now
rosie's actual it was the weirdest
feeling swear to god i look and go
me and anthony spill bong water right
there that's where that stains right
there and she goes i always wonder what
the [__] that stain is i tried to get it
out
good no it's just been there since i was
15.
now 21 like this is the lord at work
they didn't change the [__] carpet
anyway um or even like
shampoo it or some [__] it's just no no
it was very faint
it was faint but you could still see
that there was something that got
spilled
that was the bong water meaning anthony
remember when it happened he scrubbed it
forever because his mom
oh his mom would [__] him up anyway um
anyway fast forward i tell rosie hey i
got satisfaction
oh yeah but monica was she sick
her best friend oh yeah her best friend
uh
and her her best friend's best friend
basically like they're all best friends
three girls
they were coming over to hang out but
rosie's like i don't want to chill with
this [__] girl ashley over chilling
with thomas even though they were
friends she's like i'm gonna hang out
with thomas we're gonna do drugs
and it's always monica me sang a bunch
of multiple people gee this like five
people always chilling it's never
it's never once been just us together
unless we're in the kitchen we're just
talking and drinking [__] captain
morgan
so she tells me oh [__] well monica
can't come it'll just be
um she texts me and go what was it
sleepover
i think she texted me sleepover question
mark and i just like
like i backed out like imagine that
movie like what
did i look up like wonder here's huh go
sleep over what the [__]
and i text back for sure i'll come get
you
now let's do drugs so that's how that
started
i went and got her we're wearing the
exact same [__] outfit
well not on purpose and it wasn't push
trees i walked it nope i walked in i go
what the [__] we have the same outfit on
and then i remember we were leaving and
her friend that came over which i don't
show this [__] over
hanging out with thomas was looking at
us like piss and ever thinking like
that's the girl we don't need to hang
out with
that's all i felt like i don't like her
and um she's a nice person but anyway
sorry to [__] on her i don't give a [__]
um we go to my house this is how it
happened guys we go to my house
sit on the couch facing the big ass tv
doors to the left
hear things behind us we're just
chilling for long
we start drinking we got a handle of
captain morgan we start drinking
when you're on drugs alcohol means
nothing alcohol's there like water you
can drink it and not be [__] up
because
it's drug you go give a couple shots to
a meth head you know what the [__] i'm
talking about anything with like a upper
in it
makes alcohol irrelevant
you know what i'm saying that's why
people do lines and [__] drink all
night
that's why because the lions are keeping
it away all right make sense yeah
you've never done drugs it doesn't
matter you take ten drinks be fine
because uh if i started taking 10 drinks
while i'm smoking weed i'm puking you're
done you're throwing up nah not on
cocaine
anyway this has fresh [__] me and rosie
take two a piece right off the bat
and i am not trying to be weird
this is my friend i like this person so
i'm thinking
don't be a weirdo i'm trying not to make
the conversation awkward so i'm like hey
you wanna do another one and it turned
into like every time the conversation
would stop
but you wanna do more drugs wanna do
more drugs and what is it
four or five hours in me and rosie about
five each deep and he told me don't do
around
more than four and this is not it's not
like i'm bullshitting guys
that's the start of the night are you
ready about
hour four we're sitting there on the
couch we're watching the simpsons
and it was a season like one or two of
the simpsons and everything was so
bright
all the blues were so [__] bright and
i'm asking do you
do feel like the blues are overly blue
she's like yeah what the [__] so we're
just
sitting on the couch but you know what i
mean and then
i can't remember exactly how the word
started
but she told me i have a crush and she
said it got real quiet and she like said
it to me
and i go [__] it for real cause so do i
it worked out perfect i didn't have to
[__] anything up
she said that [__] first it's like hey i
have a crush and you go get the
[__] out of here sick so do i do you
want to do more drugs
that's exactly what happened guys we did
not sleep
the sun was coming up i did my count of
my bag
and we both took like 11 a piece
and we killed the [__] fifth fully
with two two liters of coke we make
mixed drinks and chug that [__]
so homeboy was off about to take the
forest sassafras oh they're not like
they don't
they're not cut with any upper like
crazy meth they're not cut with anything
stupid as [__] like the ecstasy
i don't know this is a picture of
sassafras it looks like a pineapple it's
a root it's a root it just makes you
feel like it's not like you're tripping
it just makes things a little it's like
a micro dose of mushrooms that's how it
feels
like you're like oh what the [__] you
feel like kind of gooey
but like you're just relaxed
but you're also like awake you're not
falling asleep
are people picking that out in nature i
don't know but my homie had the pills
and he goes this is sad for us
it's called sass the new [__] but we
took like 11 little tablets a
it's about six in the morning my friend
jeebs just started dating his girlfriend
now he's still dating her
just started dating her like two weeks
before that and
she spay the night and she he comes out
the room like six or seven in the
morning
rose you're still talking i think we're
watching the flintstones of john goodman
at that time
and he comes down he goes are you guys
awake still
right in the living room right on the
couch and it's right in front of his
room
and that's when i realized oh it's sun
there's sun
oh [__] and then what happened
i about to take you back at like four
hours later at 11 took her back to her
house
she was awake i was awake we didn't
do any we didn't make out we didn't do
anything we just chilled with each other
we just hung out
i think we held hands and we were all
[__] up on drugs
but we were still talking to each other
about like like just random [__] the
whole night
the conversation never stopped we're
just talking with background noise as
the me as the tv
and um i got a text from my friend that
mers from living legends mers was
playing in santa cruz and i used to go
to santa cruz
every [__] weekend to buy cds my
sister lived in santa cruz
so i would go there a lot and i went to
the catalyst to watch shows all the time
so i text rosie hey mers is playing in
santa cruz tonight
do you want to go and then she said yes
and she's like i'm awake still i know
me too these drugs [__] me up
because there's no like there's no
hangover really it's just
hey man you stayed up all night you also
took in half a fifth the [__]
captain i didn't get sick she didn't get
sick nothing i didn't throw up
nothing would check if we killed a fifth
of [__] captain
that's a lot with all that sugar from
the soda we should have puked
um i pick her and her friend monica up
we go to the catalyst well first we go
to my sister's house
which is next to the catalyst downtown
santa cruz
i go i introduce them you know i never
bring a [__] girl
i did once and it was randy because we
were going to a tech nine concert
and at the end my sister goes i don't
like that girl like oh damn
that sucks but
my sister's a dick so if somebody's
really not not overly
she doesn't like them she's gonna let me
know
i brought rosie over there and my sister
was like oh she's cool i was like ah
she is cool [__] and then and by the
way monica is
cousins rosie's best friend say monica
her cousin
is my sister's roommate she's small
world
she's wild anyway all the way in santa
cruz from merced anyway
sorry to make the story longer we go
watch merce uh the show
we're hanging out we're drinking and
right toward
the end of his set right when it's
over he's literally saying goodbye thank
you i'll be in the back sign [__]
me and rosie kissed each other i don't
know what came over us we were [__] up
i had hello sassafras still um
and then we looked at it i was like what
the [__]
all right this is ty cause you guys
another thing about me
i've like messed around with girls
before and [__] obviously but
i never had another i've never had a
girlfriend before because girls piss me
the [__] off
they are my last thing on my mind and a
lot of girls in merced
are not the girls that i'm trying to
date so there's
my mom your sister terrorizing your
whole childhood it could have been man
it could have been
them being dicks enough for me to go i
can't date that [__]
she's stupid and my mama's gonna whoop
her ass
because i gotta be you know i gotta
worry about that i'm almost [__] jew
whoop a girl's ass
she almost [__] my sister's girlfriend
oh two christmases ago
oh that's a whole nother story anyway my
mom's a psychotic-ass person if you piss
her off my sister's girlfriend pissed
her off
in her own house that's another story
anyway
um we walk outside of the catalyst we
just kiss each other walk outside the
callus it starts raining
like a romantic comedy it starts [__]
raining
and we drunkenly jog all the way to my
sisters
from downtown santa cruz it's like a
mile away we jog like in the [__]
rain
laughing all of us laughing but monica
had walked out already
i felt bad because she was like a third
wheel at that point and i like have my
jacket over all of us and we're running
down [__] pacific avenue drunk is
[__] we were
[__] up and we slept with my sisters
uh
me and rosie slept next to each other
and when i woke up it was like six in
the morning my sister's looking at me
like that
like looking at me like you're sitting
right next to this girl who is this
[__] girl
because my sister's a dick and she's
like all right because i've never had a
girlfriend
ever in my life never brought nobody to
my house nothing [__] that [__]
and um like we go back home
that morning about two days later
remember you're like uh i knew i knew
what it was with april you said that was
i knew what it was that night
um this is the fourth day and that's the
day i knew she had a red beanie on
knitted beanie still has it uh she
walked in my house and was like all
right that's it
that's the person i'm gonna be with
forever that was nine years ago
[__] crazy to think about that [__]
going on 10 years ago
so yeah my high ass just rambled but
yeah we're now engaged
wild sid rose is choosing
um but don't worry guys i filmed it i
filmed the whole thing so i'll throw
that video together
you guys are so responsible for like not
having kids and just
[__] no we both have the same business
you both have the same exact mentality
because i asked her straight up do you
want to have kids right now she goes no
go [__] good because if it was the other
way we wouldn't be together
i'm not gonna hold her not make her have
kids
because i don't want to find somebody
that wants to have kids because
i'm not gonna make you just waste your
years away you know what i mean like
that's not that's [__] up
but saying we've agreed on everything
even down to the marriage thing we
talked about like i don't have time for
that [__]
and now it's more of like the best part
about being gay i mean it's not like we
did it on purpose but
i don't have to invite everybody not
enough to invite everybody i know and go
sorry bro you know with covet and [__]
[Laughter]
[__] it what was it like uh glenn
ghoulia a
[__] wedding singer the only good
thing he said i don't want to pay for a
bunch of strangers to have free drinks
and fish
for real i don't like when [__]
bring random people that never meant to
parties and [__]
and you want me to pay imagine that
right now you throw a party at your
house you're [__] high school
you buy all the beer one person you
invite fights five people
that happens five times 25 extra people
at your [__] drinking up all your [__]
you never even met they didn't even know
that's your house
now amplify that to a wedding
now i put in perspective for you [__]
that [__]
[__] all that noise i know hell no
but it's true the scovid regulation
[__] i can't be inviting
everybody
and plus i don't want a bunch of people
there i really i truly don't
i don't have to work because i'm i'm
like a host in life
at my house like make sure every
[__] is cool but you guys are
all cool
cool when they all leave then i get to
have fun it's the biggest hosting event
it's the biggest hosting event i
remember thinking that yep
it really is it is it is i just want to
make sure people aren't too faded
uh my dad does not drink so i'm like i
don't want a bunch of [__]
around my dad who used to be an
alcoholic and
that's [__] rude but i can't also be
like yo don't drink at the wedding
go over there that's my dad you know i
don't want to and make my dad feel like
he's excluded from [__]
so i don't want to punch him
[__] and i can't be having weed
smoke everywhere because my grandma's
going to be there
me and rosie thought about this after
six like grandma i'll let you know
after six everybody's gonna start
drinking she won't drink either like i'm
gonna start drinking and stuff because
at six
every kid's gotta go everybody's gotta
go and that's when the giant joints come
out
that's when the dabs come out i'm gonna
[__] have pounds and pounds of weed
[__] it why not it's our wedding it's
the coolest
it's gonna be the coolest and then we're
gonna pull up pam and jim
and then go get married niagara falls
and give a really look
to the camera and almost ruin the
episode
sorry marty my life is the office uh me
rosie are doing good we're clean right
now we haven't watched the office like
maybe a month and a half we gotta stop
watching it every day
so we're clean sober um so yeah guys me
rosie engaged the long version of that
sorry that took for [__] ever um
yeah we went to merced man and i want to
hop into something else
about merced yes the crow brandon lee
the crow
it's i'm not gonna talk about the move
no movie reviews today
uh for all you guys that are wondering
why i brought up the crow some 18 pound
crow just flew over
oh it was ominous that was creepy one
thing about merced i know and then the
[__]
death crow came by um every time i go
back
every time i go back and talk to i only
have like three friends left
all right i don't talk to a lot of these
guys in the story time anymore because i
can't deal with that [__]
i've talked about this guy before i'm
not gonna bring his name up but i've
talked about this guy in a story time
before
and he wasn't [__] up
i'm talking to my friend anthony
anthony's married to this girl nicole
which is rosie's good friend now
so rosie uh my friend anthony one from
story time his wife is super cool
so we're over there we're talking to him
we just got engaged they're like oh
they're all hyped up and [__] right
um so we're talking we're just talking
smoking bowls and they start telling i
ask about
to ask about a certain friend and he
just like goes [__] [__]
oh what what the [__] happened to him
because my first thing is like oh my god
is he [__] dead and nobody told me
because i'm in l.a dude not everybody
[__] texts me people have their lives
they got kids
they're not thinking let me text every
person that's ever known this guy
they're not thinking that
so the first thing i think is no is he
[__] dead no no
i'm just like a lot of my friends have
died it just sucks
so he starts telling me that one of our
friends one of my friends that used to
be
someone you look up to he was younger
than me and i looked at him like
you are so [__] cool this
[__] was a pro
a pro professional motocross writer
at like 12 years old i met him when he
was about 15 to 16.
i'm like a year or two years older than
him
pro he's a [__] pro he gets paid and
he's a [__]
one of the top ranked call of duty
players so he's out there killing [__]
back when you can like
25 and 50 kill streak drops a bomb on
the map or
i didn't really play it that much but i
remember he's always getting him back to
back with
hella kills no deaths he's just he's all
around just a dope ass dude
so that motherfucker's done he showed me
a picture and i couldn't even recognize
his ass
the only you know what i did recognize
him
it's like when you get a picture of
yourself and then you do a face swap and
put the put the drug addict filter on
that's what the [__] it was because he
had the same hat beanie that he
always rocks the same [__]
same haircut man that he always rocked
missing ass teeth
aged he's older looks older than me i'm
young i'm older than him
he looks 15 years older than i do
look [__] up got caught a hell of
heroin ella pills
like it's just there's a crow again
[__] it's just bad dude it's just
it's so weird to see my friends
disintegrate
and i know last episode a lot of you're
like wait how old are you you know how
many people think i'm like 23
a lot i noticed that a lot of people
think i'm like 23 24.
i'm 30 [__] 1 years old i'm i am
water boy age okay i'm a full grown
person if i went back to college right
now they'd be like damn this fool must
be slow
so i i'm the water boy age all right
this fool looks 40. i get mistaken for
23.
24 people like how are you like 24 25
like this
damn i forgot when i was 24 oh yeah i
was high
um so yeah so seeing my friends
disintegrate
seeing joe's just
gone liza's gone ryan's gone
nick's [__] dead george dead
god all my best friends all drugs
all jokes all meth
meth pills heroin
um my friend george
from merced got killed in chicago in a
lobby in a hotel
shot in the head so he must have been
dabbling in some [__] out there
you don't just get shot in the head as a
white kid in chicago randomly in a hotel
lobby
probably owe somebody money probably owe
somebody money sad
because i just think of burn ass george
doing dumb like doing dumb show over
skating
that's when i think of people when they
die or when they get old and get on
drugs i think of when i met him
i think of the kid version and it makes
me so [__] sad because
i can remember vividly going back you
want me to be 15 i can go right back
into my head who
am i with i know where we're at when i
met him i can see it i can see what they
look like i know what i look like i look
the [__] same
you know what i mean [__] same and
i can see when i first met him when i
first met joe i
first met every one of these guys and
and it makes me so [__] sad to think
like yo you guys are never coming back
you guys are drug you're strong out you
you want you you want drugs more than
anything in the planet more than your
life
you kill yourself and someone's like
y'all give you free hits for a year but
you got to kill yourself after a year
i'm down that's exactly what a drug
addict does because they care about now
when can i get that's why they steal
because they manage it right now
um it's [__] up seeing my homies mug
shot and he was like one of the best
ones
we didn't chill with him all the time
because why he was broken back
broken leg because he's in the motocross
circuit he's always [__] himself up
but he's getting paid
as a kid home schooled because he was
such a ball and ass [__]
dirt bike rider that he would go on tour
he's homeschooled he worked on the road
he's that kid
the kid we all strive to be and now he's
just [__]
i was just seeing his mug shot made me
so [__] sad it was so weird to see
that [__]
and uh that's merced that's what it
turned into
um jeeps anthony they're still around
6'5 still around but that's it after
every single other person you've ever
heard in story time's gone
every single one every right now if you
watch story time you know how many
friends i've named
those three friends are the only ones
left
that's it it's a lot of [__]
man
it's a lot of people living outside and
[__]
ew pisses me off
on to the next topic because that got
boring
that got depressing so um
let me talk about something super sick
i'm sorry to all my homies literally my
[__] friends
um sorry i'm sorry
i need help i'll help you none of you
guys have asked or even taken the offer
i'm tired of trying to help
[__] don't want it so
um here we go on to something super
tight if you're in the car i'm sorry for
depressing
the [__] out of you here we go it's good
news bad news good news me or as you get
engaged my friends are dying
um good news you guys ready
so you guys know this about us we we
don't
get paid by youtube we don't get paid by
any of that [__] we do all that [__] for
[__] free essentially
we pay for come out of pocket for
everything right you guys know that we
don't get ads you guys we get ads on
dopaziola channel and we don't get paid
youtube still chooses to run ads and we
don't get paid from it i'm not hating on
youtube
which a lot of you know i should be let
it go
[__] if they want to pay me pay me if
not i'm still going to make content
anyway you guys ready for this [__] as
you can tell because in this episode
there was a [__] sponsored ad
as you guys know podcasting they do oh
beef jerky the best
beef jerky you know they do ad reads and
[__] right they hold the paper and go
this is the this is the stuff you should
buy
so they're normal people they get to get
paid
imagine being a normal like comedian
podcaster that has never heard of
getting deleted
23 times have been deleted off instagram
1.5 million whatever you want to call it
all those followers gone
we've been deleted on youtube we've been
shadow been on youtube for two years
shadow band for all you people that
don't know what that means is uh they
try to make you non-existent your page
is there
but you gotta [__] type their name in
and go touch their page
and then it pops up you can't type the
name and the name pops up it doesn't
work like that it's called
man so they basically funnel all our
traffic off but they still do
advertisements on our [__] which pisses
me off
anyway you ready for the good news we're
finally like the other kids we're normal
we're normal we just got us we just
marty and i
marty and i officially are signed with
an ad agency for the podcast
and you know what that means ladies and
gentlemen you know what that means
we're finally gonna get [__] paid to
do stuff that we love because before
we're coming out of pocket and now we're
like normal kids because we're not
sitting here [__]
showing pounds and stuff so we're okay
to advertise
are you guys ready for this for everyone
out there here's the ultimate [__] i put
my joint down you guys know i don't do
that [__]
you guys ready for this how epic this
news is we just signed with an ad agency
and we just got a sponsor
that means when you do the ad reads that
you see on
you know all the big podcasts that's us
now
yeah marty yeah that's us now
so for everyone out there yeah it's a
business we [__] you guys
this is two hour podcast already
for us to do this costs money costs time
martial isn't forever
far mario as far as [__] um
we finally get paid to do ad reads guys
and for future ad for we're getting
other sponsors of course we're getting
this we want to make little commercials
and little
skits and not the regular ad read you
know what i'm saying unless it calls for
that if a certain brand wants
this and that that's what we're going to
do if we like the brand we're not just
going to
take everything [__] that [__] we're
only going to do what we
want to do is the co is the company okay
is it something we [__] with
that's the main thing we're not just
sitting here check out this toothpaste
it's [__] toothpaste like that's not
what we're doing first thing we told
them is it has to be off yeah it has to
be authentic
we made it in the contract marty we they
sent us a contract and marty sent them a
con
send them all these things back and they
said just write your own contract don't
go and send it to us then
and then we put in there creative
control you have none
we have every right to do whatever we
want like it's
it's to the t we couldn't have asked for
more of
stuff we wanted we did it all they want
they agreed with everything so guys
officially officially as of like last
week
we are a sponsored podcast now we are
now getting paid to
do this and i'm so [__] happy and for
everyone out there i know there's a
people you sold out
no selling out means you had to be
getting paid already
we didn't sell anything all we did was
go hey
we'll take that money we'll do a
sponsored ad for you so bam here's an ad
read
thanks for sitting through that fans we
just got we just paid our rent
like you you see what i'm saying we do
this whole podcast and then read a one
minute ad read
you can [__] suck a dick if you don't
like it like come on man
that's how we're supposed to get paid so
for uh that's one of the easier
easier thoughts we we aren't for
everyone out there you signed a contract
you sold your soul nah
we made our own contract and they signed
ours basically
that's pretty much how it went you sent
a contract to them they signed the [__]
and now here we are basically yeah they
were amazing they were such a they were
so flexible with us yeah
so and the more we're able to grow this
it just puts us in a position to do more
thank you
thank you so much what is it 20 hours a
day for nothing
just doing it because we want to do the
podcast and now that we have someone
that can help alleviate those financial
[__]
problems yeah we're not rich marty's not
rich i'm not [__] rich
we we are self-sufficient we he owns a
little company i own my own company
that's how we pay bills
so for everyone out there i wish i could
support and buy merch you don't have to
do that [__]
supporting is just watching
and like leave a comment when we do ad
reads and the
stuff you see a commercial that we do a
little ad read in the podcast
don't skip through it watch it that
would help us
if it's an app download the app if it's
for free
help me out [__] damn we're
trying to get [__] paid over you and
and you always hear podcasters try to
make it authentic and go
we really love this company and you know
there are good friends
i don't [__] know these companies the
[__] we get a one page and go all right
they seem cool let's do some more
research on them and before we say yeah
the [__] no hell no we you guys know me
i'm not gonna sugarcoat the [__]
i'm letting you right know right now if
you see an ad read
unless i go this is my [__] friend's
company i don't know this [__]
company
and i'm being real with you these ads
and all the stuff we're gonna start
doing
is so we can get [__] paid
there's nothing else about it i'm not
sugarcoating [__] i use this
every day maybe i do maybe i don't i'll
let you know for real you guys know that
so that's the other part about our deal
is that they're unscripted
yes unscripted we don't have to say [__]
that they give us
we get the one page of their information
with their links all right cool research
you think i'm going to [__] just
throw a company up here and it turns out
they're [__] creeps
hell no we have to sign a contract per
company that's in our own contract
we have to we have to review each
company and allow you to give it to us
because we're not just going to read
some [__] or some [__]
dumb stuff that we're not going to no
it's not going to happen
the first thing i said is the most
important thing is his
authenticity and people trust that what
we're affiliated with
is it's not some scam and [__] so
guys
this is what i'm asking for you that's
what i'm asking from you
if we do an ad read and it don't cost
you money and it's not even interest if
it doesn't interest you and doesn't cost
you money
download that app help me out if if
it's for something we're doing for uh
let's say stereo
gosh you're nothing to download that app
that'd be sick if you followed us
thank you do you see what i'm saying
even if you don't use that [__] help
help me out [__] damn
um so yeah for the adwords guys i'm
transparent with you
i tell you all the time you guys know
you
how many times i said we don't do this
[__] for money it's because we want to
do it
we're still doing two hour podcast dope
is yola channel just
eight years for the hope to parlay into
something into something like this
exactly you guys know that
we get [__] with online all the time
you guys know that
help me out give us a win by just
watching
watch and listen drop a like like i said
earlier but now that we have ad reads
watch the ad read if it's something you
like and you want to buy it
use our [__] code help us out you
guys got to remember every time
i'm be straight transparent with you
every time you help us out you use a
code
marty and i get paid
the podcast gets paid yeah yeah the
podcast you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah but still
the podcast gets paid but do you see
what i'm saying man this is
time finally time for us to come up
marty was grew up with no money
same here so this is the time for us to
actually what was it a little dicky uh
save that money this is essentially time
for me to save that money remember he's
doing the weed maps ad you remember that
[__]
for real come on man we've been doing
this [__] for we
look it nothing changes nothing changes
about the show
except the extra one minute or two
except that it gets better too
it gets better because the more we get
we can do more
[__] better cameras and all that stuff
um and then also i mean it's important
to note too that the goal is once this
pandemic lifts is to parlay this into
live shows coming to your city
yeah we haven't talked about that that's
the whole point guys i want to do this
live
i want to do this live in a different
state smoke joints on stage
we're just talking about that we got to
go to states where i won't get arrested
so i would hate to go hey thanks for
coming out guys just get handcuffed
it's going to happen i'm not going to
say it's not going to happen it's going
to happen at least once
but i would i'd rather not but yeah
that's the whole point of this podcast
we want to do this live we're going to
do more
there's a lot of stuff coming up guys
the pandemic really
[__] molested everybody's pockets and
[__] everything up
so yeah ad reads we got sponsored guys
we signed a contract
yeah i'm happy i'm [__] stoked as
hell
just because i know how long we did you
guys remember we were in this warehouse
everything is out of pocket everything
push trees makes everything revolve and
work
revolver i mean uh evolve and um
that's entrepreneurship that's the fact
that it is definition you want to hear
something [__] really cool
i don't even tell you last night rosie
and i got an uber
with this girl leslie we had an uber
from because we took our car in to get
the oil change and they weren't going to
be done
uh at mercedes they like to go hey man
takes 19 hours for an oil change so
um we uh get the uber uh she's this
girl's
off the bat super cool super cool chick
right
she's writing an uber this is what it
means by [__] hustling because that
girl is gonna be where we are
and we're not even [__] coming up yet
she
is a designer starts talking about she
makes plus size she was a big girl she
makes plus
size fashion couture [__]
right this girl is about to be a new uh
in la fashion week this month or she's
going to be in la fashion where she did
this one i can't remember
she literally said i was up to four of
them we started talking about like yeah
we're up to five in the morning
we had to get up and still do [__] we
got to go we were about to go do orders
when she dropped us off at the warehouse
we were going straight there to do
orders and she's like wait you guys do
cold like yeah
volleyball we're in you know year seven
year eight she's like oh i'm year five
she was in new york fashion week she did
a bunch of [__]
just hearing what she said it sounds
like rosie and ours
our day okay i was up till four doing
these sketches and then you know i
didn't have time to eat because i forget
to eat i'm like yeah
us too every day our friends got a
reminder she's like mine too
she's like i have grapes right here she
had a bag of grapes like this one i've
been eating
because i was [__] need to get on the
road so she works uber in the day
does all her fashion designs all through
the night wakes up does uber the day
sells her stuff online um i can't
remember the name of it i
wrote it down i wrote it down in my
notes but
how cool that's entrepreneurship man
she's working uber all day and she's
like i'll take breaks
answer these comments get back pick
somebody up take a rant or comment like
that's us rosie i'm in the shower
sometimes answering comments i'm getting
the shower like this with my hand out
all the time all the time because it's
the time i had it's the part of my day
where i
have time where i'm just sitting in the
shower like i'm tired
i answer comments and i leave it right
there on the top of the toilet and i
[__] finish my shower
get out answer [__] comments for
another hour that's my day starts
so hearing her go through the same thing
was [__] cool
like he rang like the same exact layout
having problems with certain manufacture
having problems with this people buying
[__] oh my god
this girl was dead on what we were on
and yeah that goes back to the
sponsorships me and rosie
we've done 300 different cannabis cup i
mean events
pop-ups renting our hotels doing this
carrying everything
doing all of our stuff standing there
all [__] day taking pictures
giving [__] to people for years years
and years and years and years just so we
could pay our bills and make videos
we weren't getting paid off any of the
content we just did it because we filed
rosie's down because she could have said
dude we're spending all your money on
the [__] videos
and doing all this stuff and paying for
production i know
but we're going to be rich one day like
it's all for something
it's all for something please trust me
i'm having the same conversation telling
you like
it's gonna work i promise and that's
where it's all come down to is rosie's
never been a dick about it
she's never been a george young mom
being a dick
george young from blow like oh my god is
that real
[__] [__] ass mom rosie's never
been that girl ever
so it's really cool that it's
finally starting to work when me and
marty went what happened we got off the
phone with the
ad agency who called each other
immediately like yo
for real what
get the [__] out of here it's crazy when
something works
and it actually worked and we see a
number go oh
it's worth it it all worked out it
worked
it worked out there's been so many
things in my career it's just flatlined
losing money but i love what we made
like exactly you ever do that like i
love this so much but i lost three
thousand dollars on it and i only had
four thousand dollars
how many times i've been dude and people
like you have pounds and all this [__]
when i first started i was selling weed
do you know how much money you can make
on a pound one hundred to two hundred
dollars
when you're selling in bulk you gotta
remember when it's competitive and go yo
ten pack of those [__] cookies is
like or this girl scout cookies is i
don't know [__] 20 bands because two
bam
two pounds uh two bands a piece okay but
my homie's gonna give him
19. but i got him for 19. so i was gonna
make a hundred
now it's like cool can you do 19.50 cool
now my profits are split in [__] half
and it were you know many times i broke
even just to get the packs off because i
already bought them
a lot and then a lot of you
[__] out there doing this
uh-huh uh-huh same exact thing counting
trying to count your money i'll go
right right we just did that [__] that
was me man
it would happen i would take trips for
[__] ten packs and make a band
one thousand dollars off a ten pack and
a drive and a risk
damn so back then i was still broke
our rent was 600 when i started doing
instagram i stopped selling weed
because i don't want to get my door
kicked in what happens when you stop
selling weed you don't make no more
[__] money
i gotta get a job i had a good job with
u-haul and i was barely making my rent
and living life like living and getting
like you know getting groceries and
electricity in your phone
it's not just rent you know what i'm
saying rosie had a job when we first
started dating too
i was barely making rent while making
content and [__] because i knew like i
got to leave the wii ship behind
because even though [__] still
need packs i just sent him somewhere
else going nah brother
you got to hit him up now and i just
stopped selling weed even though i was
selling a
lot of weed and you're like you sold a
lot of we didn't have no money saved
[__] not in a money save who saves money
when you're ignorant
we i spent when we first started dating
i was not broke
when we first started hanging out i was
not broke when we first started dating i
was
broke i remember it was a one week into
dating
we were going to kfc and in my mind i
was pulling
what's up with the tasha bell today i
was pulling a half baked like
three dollars in my head just
subtractions like all right i got 80
cents left i had like 22 bucks in my
hand
in my pocket and i remember we were
getting food
and rosie's friend called and goes oh
you're up kfc can you get this and like
yeah
[__] and it came out to like 18
something and i thought
oh no no no this is not gonna work and
that's the first time in a long time
because i
had money i had grips of [__] money
all the time living with jeeps when i
first started i had a dispensary
essentially i had [__] stacks
everywhere to nothing
in the course of like six months
it was weird because right before i
started dating rosie is when john went
missing
and when he went missing i had no
connect for like four months five months
and i was getting zips off of people and
[__] qp's getting that's when i met
[__] stinky ass dan from the last
[__]
podcast that's how i met him because
john was missing so for those time
period of times i was
broke as [__] because i had no revenue
at all i had no [__] money coming in
i was working the pizza place yeah but
you don't make a lot of money doing
pizza [__] when my rents are ready
you you feel me if you've ever been
broke you [__] feel me it's
there's never enough money anyway those
right when i started dating rosie is
when um
john went missing so i wasn't really
selling a shitload of weed anymore
but i started dating her so when i
started dating rosie i was
[__] broke i was broke i still saw we
right when we started dating i was still
selling weed
but i stopped like a year after we
started dating which was like what eight
or nine years ago
yeah i stopped selling weed um
but yeah i started instagram and i
wasn't going to go back to selling weed
like i had to stop
as soon as i started getting a little
popularity like like 3 000 followers and
somebody hit me
yo is that you on instagram going oh
hell no
gone i'm done turned it off just stopped
i just
let the packs go i just let it go i
stopped answering the phone
i had a different number i just had to
stop or go to jail i was gonna go to
jail i can't be online posting my face
with weed
it just didn't work out i had to stop or
i'd be in jail right now
anyway that's what comes back to it i
know i went on a long ass rant story
but [__] download the apps that
we talked about on these sponsorships
go buy it and when you at the 7-eleven
go yo
thomas said me he have no idea what the
[__] you're talking about
but at least at least the support like
so yeah man i stopped i literally
stopped my life of luxury assassin's
money
i was balling for quite a few years just
by myself
not doing nothing just spending it all
on cds and food and [__] drugs
that's it i had no money i was making so
much money with weed just
squandering the [__] i bought a car
paid my rent for [__] three four
years like yeah
there you go so much anyway um that was
broke as [__] and then
we stopped selling we started doing
content for free and we've been doing
content for free until 2019 from that
day
from that day i said i gotta stop
selling weed i have
not been making money isn't that crazy
think about that rosie you have been
with me since i started being broke
so any [__] out there saying
that she's not really down
rosie was chilling with me when i had
money
hanging out and drinking started dating
i had no more money
nothing ever changed rosie had two jobs
you're
[__] right
where she was down she had two [__]
jobs when i started dating her she she
was going to work at like three in the
morning she's [__] down
and um yeah i told her like yo we're
gonna be broke for a while
i need to get this contest you know i
was like 2014 15 like we should we
should move to la
i know we don't get paid for it we'll
make it work
we'll sell more clothes and the clothes
there was times where we're like yo we
got to sell these clothes
just to pay our rent yeah we only had
stickers and [__] when we first got here
it was rough and our rent was quadrupled
from merced
it went from 600 at our house to 2400
apartment downtown
and when we're signing the lease i'm
going
like getting sick but i remember
thinking we're already here
we're already here the u-haul's here
oh i can't do it and then
made it work every time our rents got
more expensive we've just made it work
because we have to and now we're doing
okay
we're okay and
download these apps it keeps going back
to it we finally sponsored all right we
have sponsor [__] ads uh
don't be a [__] don't be an [__]
just [__] watch them i feel like
people
seem to appreciate this whole story
we've been doing it for [__] free and
if it only does this
and you can help me out okay help me out
jesus christ
there'll be an i would give you some
nugs so give me some [__] download
it's free i had to pay for the weed um
yeah so that was a long s good news
sponsorship to
where we're broke damn it's so weird to
think about how [__] much i've
stressed out
over the past like 10 years it's crazy
being completely stressed and not
letting everybody know about it
oh my god um
but yeah there we are that was a
that was fun things are moving we
secured this after three episodes that
was because of that
wave of support we got yes coming out of
the gate that's why we got to even
got the contract because you guys were
so [__] on it so thank you
um tell your [__] friends watch
thank you guys for leaving likes thank
you guys for commenting thank you for
all that [__]
excuse me if you're on spotify or apple
i think you can leave a review
if you like the episode leave a review
that helps us out a lot actually
excuse me [__] jesus because the goal
really is to be the
one of the biggest baddest top podcast
in the world and that's the goal beyond
this first season and just keeping it
really going so
because the way i see it is you guys
want content
the bigger our podcast is the bigger
guest we can get
the bigger guests the more views the
more views the more we get paid the more
we get paid the less we gotta [__]
stress in life
and just worry about the podcast man
it's just for real
because remember when we're not getting
paid for something
it's a hobby you know what i mean now
it's job
it was always a job for time and for how
much dedication we put into this [__]
marty added this [__] how long it takes
to edit
a long time but yeah and we remember the
regular dope as yolo challenge we still
come out of pocket for all of this stuff
so it's just thanks thanks guys the bong
drop went [__] amazing thank you guys
for buying up hellabongs pushers.com
um yeah pushtrees.com guys that's our
clothing company go check it out we just
dropped a skateboard collection
we have a bunch of stuff go check it out
also
for the podcast check out the clips
channel that's almost enough time to get
monetized on that channel
also we are monetized on this channel
the channel you're watching right now
dopa's
uh usual podcast youtube said
yeah isn't that [__] crazy they were
like
kind of go ahead go ahead oh limited ass
oh damn you [__]
hey as i remember when joey diaz talked
about getting his dick sucked by some
chick
and it was graphic that was monetized
i love that man he's vulgar which is
amazing and they're like yo
you're good and all these other
podcasters talking about death and vlad
tv talking about
actual murders that shit's monetized i'm
only talking about being broke
come on entrepreneurship come on damn
come on give us our ad suitability i'm
in the back end reading all these terms
and [__] hey yeah we're unlimited right
now but it's all good
it's all good thank you guys for
watching and leaving comments and liking
thank you so much
leave a comment leave a like i drop uh
damn it i appreciate you guys thank you
so much
uh like i said spotify all streaming
platforms apple music google podcast
uh amazon music i heart radio and i'm
acting like i know all these [__]
play i don't know all the platforms but
you guys see at the end of this podcast
there's a little screen that shows you
everything we're on dope as usual across
everything dope as usual podcasts on
youtube
on um twitter we just started twitter
also check it out it's in the
description
if you ever need to find our social
medias go below the video on youtube go
below on spotify
any any streaming app has all our links
right below the episode has all of our
links be sure to follow us subscribe
whatever it is
thank you guys so much for watching
appreciate it we are gonna get on out of
here it's been
oh [__] 220 get the [__] out of here
i looked and it was 114. then you
started going off about the uh yeah
yeah one way yeah it really took an hour
to tell that story
oh i'm back on sassafrass over here man
i'm over here on drugs again
is it sun dude i haven't talked about
strip clubs yet but
i have a strip club in the and the earth
sun story
i'll leave you intrigued all right till
next time um thank you guys so much for
watching this joint lasted the whole
time always
this joint lasted for a while thank you
guys so much for watching
this is the dope as usual podcast the
dopest podcast in the world thank you
guys so much
i appreciate you watching for marty and
i thank you so much for watching
have a dope ass day later guys all right
damn 220 get the [__] out of here
what is this it's been
one week since you looked at me what's
up guys real quick i wanted to talk to
you about epidemic sound this is
something that marty and i have been
using well marty introduced me to this
about
18 months ago i have used it every
[__] day since every video everything
i do
do you ever upload music to instagram or
youtube and you get a copyright strike
this is basically what this is for this
alleviates all those [__] problems
this is royalty free music
the second you go on this site you can
get sounds you can get this
a bird going by songs anything like that
anything that fits your content
you can use as long as you have an
account you cannot get a copyright
strike
just to be 100 honest guys i pay for
monthly
uh payments to epidemic sound because i
have four different youtube channels
i you i swear by this [__] if you're in
my dm you always ask me where to be i
always say epidemic sound
it's something we use for everything so
we teamed up with epidemic sound guys
this is what we're offering you guys
free 30-day trial that's it free 30-day
trial within that 30 days whatever you
use whatever you post whatever it's
linked
to will not get copyright strikes you
can't get taken down if it's a song
it's royalty free music there's good ass
mute i mean
everything every song you've ever seen
on the dopa joel channel the adventures
channel
this channel is all from epidemic sound
no strings attached at all guys all you
gotta do is click the link in our
description or go to yololinks.com
music you can go on our instagram click
it and it'll say music and go on my
instagram adobe zola click it'll say
music
all you have to do is sign up that's it
it's free you can go by mood go by genre
go by feeling it's
very cool if you want to have a scary
sound there's
500 the only problem with epidemic sound
is you're going to be on there for so
[__] long because one sound has 70
variations
so you can you can make a movie with
this website so if you do music you do
content creation or if you just want to
check it out free 30-day trial all you
do is use your email all you do is sign
up that's it
you won't get charged nothing like that
free 30-day trial but make sure you
click the link in our description
click the link in our description or
like i said go to yolalynx.com
music it's a free 30-day trial
[Music]
perfect perfect
you